I found a simple, repeatable trading
strategy that has helped turn losing
traders into consistently profitable
ones. This hasn't just worked for me,
but for thousands of struggling traders
who were losing thousands of dollars
before learning this strategy. And the
reason I'm confident teaching this is
simple. This isn't theory. Real traders
are using this with real money and
getting consistent results. Most traders
don't fail because they're not smart
enough. They fail because they're
overwhelmed. Too many strategies, too
much noise, and no clear trading
roadmap. This is the road map I wish I
had when I first started. And it's what
every trader needs from day one to
become consistently profitable. Whether
you're starting from absolute zero or
you've been trading and feeling stuck
for a while, this is a complete start to
finish guide designed to take you from
beginner all the way to confidently
executing trades. This is a full 3-hour
master class, and by the end of it, you
should understand trading well enough
that you do not need to watch 10 other
videos to fill in the gaps. We'll start
with the foundation most traders skip.
How the markets actually move, how to
think in probabilities, how trading risk
really works, and what consistently
becoming profitable truly means. Then
I'll show you how to read charts step by
step from the basics all the way to
identifying high probability areas in
the market that you can make money from.
From there, I'll break down the exact
strategy that has helped so many
struggling traders finally become
consistently profitable. And I'll walk
through real examples, real trades to
show you exactly how to execute it. This
isn't a simple overview or a highlight
reel. It's a complete trading system
taught from scratch with nothing
skipped. And again, this works. traders
are using this already to consistently
make money. If you're willing to
actually put in the time to watch this
video, this will probably be the only
video you ever need to watch. So, let's
start at the beginning so you can build
a foundation for trading success. So,
let's talk about the simples of how the
markets work. Over here, I have a chart
open. Let's not worry about anything
else other than just how and why the
market goes up and down. This is a
representation of the mass psychology
and people trading this market. It
doesn't matter what you're looking at,
but that is what price of these up and
down movements represents of buyers and
sellers coming in of either traders and
investors like you and me or big banks,
big hedge funds, algorithms, everyone
that is participating in this market.
And essentially what causes the price to
move down or up over time is the
imbalances between buyers and sellers.
What caused the market to move down
right here was there was a lot more
people wanting to sell than buy. And
this imbalance pushes the market down.
And then eventually it got to a point
where that imbalance was filled and then
it flipped and a lot more people started
to want to buy. There was a lot more
demand in the market. And so that's what
pushed this up over time. And these
little imbalances, you can see if you
zoom more into the chart, will go up and
down over time in the smaller points in
the market. And this is what volatility
is called. These up and down movements.
These create on a smaller time frame
trading opportunities that we'll talk
about later. Now, how you make money
trading is let's say this is a stock
chart of let's say Apple and down here
it's trading at $100.
If we buy 10 shares at $100 and it moves
up here to let's say 105 and we sell
those 10 shares, the amount of profit
we'll make is this difference of $5 that
it moved up times the 10 shares we
purchased. So we will make $50 over that
time frame trading. And so this is the
whole idea of how you make money trading
is you buy at a certain price and then
sell at another price to make that
difference. And so this is actually a
chart of the S&P 500 futures. And
normally over a year of long-term
investing, you can expect to get, let's
say, 10% return on average long-term
investing in the S&P 500. This is your
basic safe investment. And so if you
took $100, you would get $110 after one
year. But when it comes to trading, you
can take something like that $100 and
you can turn it into $300 in a matter of
days or weeks or even minutes depending
on your strategy and your time frame
that you're trading. But unlike
long-term investing is you can lose all
of this $100 in that same time frame as
well compared to if you invest in the
overall S&P 500 future stock market.
Well, for that $100 to go to zero, the
stock market has to go to zero, and
you're probably going to have bigger
issues than losing your $100 if that
happens. So, there's a lot more risk
involved, but the reward is higher if,
again, you can master some key steps.
And so, here's a quick example of a
trade I took on a one minute chart. So,
it's a lot faster paced. I saw
essentially a couple key factors of why
I thought it was important to buy down
here and then I thought the marker would
reverse up and then I bet that it would
go up risking $1,700.
And then if it goes up here I make, you
know, about $5,000. I think on this
trade I made roughly $4,500 over about
15 minutes. So that's really fast-paced.
Again, there's trades where I lose
essentially that $1,700 in 15 minutes.
So that risk is there as well, but the
math and strategy over time play out in
my favor. And we'll talk about how that
works in a minute, but you're not going
to be making that much money right away.
It took me years to scale my account to
be risking that much at once. When I
first started, I was risking $50 a
trade. And over time, I scaled and got
bigger and bigger. And so what the
trading journey looks like as you start
out, you're probably going to be either
losing money slowly over time or you're
going to be break even and really not
making that much because it's just going
to take time to get used to what you're
doing, how trading works, and mastering
your strategy and your emotions and
psychology that we'll talk about in a
second that really make or break your
trading. And then eventually what will
happen is you will start to find some
consistent profitability when you nail
down a trading strategy. But because
you're trading small size, it's not
going to be that much right away. But
don't focus on the money initially. That
is what ruins traders. Even me recently
when I sized up to this current size I'm
at, I went on emotional roller coaster
spiral and lost a lot of money because I
started focusing on the money way too
much. I started thinking, "Holy cow, I
can now make $5,000 in 15 minutes." And
that really messed with my ability to
consistently execute the strategy. But
eventually, as you size up, that $10
will start to become $50, $100, $200,
and then your equity curve and how much
you're making will go parabolic in the
essential. It'll be an an exponential
graph because you're not making $10
anymore. You're now making $100. and
then you're making a thousand dollar per
trade. And so that'll slowly happen over
time, years potentially, but that's
where the real money comes trading. Now,
when it comes to what you should
actually trade, you can choose anything
that you want. But over my years, I
trade stocks, options, crypto, forex,
and futures. And what I've realized over
time is futures is the best thing to
trade if you want to start out with a
small account. but still be able to get
a lot of leverage. Trading the S&P 500
futures has something like 450 to 500
times leverage, which is insane. But
essentially, what it allows you to do is
participate in trading where you only
need $50 in your account to get started.
I would suggest having a little bit more
than that, maybe something like 500
because if you lose one trade, you know,
you're going to have to redeposit money,
but you can essentially get use this $50
to enter in a trade and even be risking
less than that, maybe even $20. We'll
talk about and I'll show you some trade
examples in a minute here. But what it
allows you to do is able to say, "Hey, I
want to risk $20 in this trade and I
will try and triple that and make $60."
And so you can start out really small
because again going back to this journey
is in the beginning you need to just be
focusing on learning because you're
going to lose money most likely or
you're going to just be break even for a
while. You may have streaks where maybe
you make money for a week or two but
then you'll give it back up because the
market is really really hard to trade
over a long period of time. There's
different market cycles that cause you
to have to adjust and if you don't know
how to do it because you're not
experienced you'll lose money. Now, when
it comes to a trading platform and tools
to use, I highly recommend checking out
this platform. It's what I've used for
over five years now for trading futures.
It's called Ninja Trader. I'll leave a
link for it in the description below or
you can use this QR code and it's super
super powerful for trading futures. You
can easily draw and use any basic
charting software you need. But the
ability to be able to manage trades
super easily by moving up your, you
know, your stop-loss or moving around
your targets of profit just with a click
of a button and a chart and as well a
tool that I have created for it where I
can easily have the system tell me how
many contracts I need to trade. we'll
talk about in a minute to you know risk
a certain target and you know
continuously stick to that proper risk
is super super powerful and the biggest
thing is what this will give you access
to is your candlestick charts which are
super important for really deep diving
into what is going on with the markets
and reading the price movements that
will really really help you in the long
term. Now, prior to candlestick charts,
we had just simple line charts that is
essentially just connecting two dots or
more. Now, instead, candlesticks give us
four points of data. And you can see
comparing these two charts, there's a
lot of data down here that you're
missing in the line chart. That's why
candlestick charts are so important.
Candlestick charts give you four points
of data. They give you the closing
price, the opening price, and the
extreme low and high of that
candlestick. A green candlestick
signifies that the price went up over
the candlestick, and a red signifies
that it went down. And then what you
have outside of the body of the
candlestick is you have what's called a
wick. And essentially, this just shows
you where the price moved to the extreme
high before it ended up closing or
opening at the price the candlestick
closed at. And then candlesticks can
also represent different time periods.
One candlestick can be changed to
represent any amount of time or volume,
but the idea is that it represents a
certain amount of data. a lot of the
time and most commonly it's a timebased
chart where one candlestick can
represent 1 minute, 10 minutes, 30
minutes, an hour, a day, a week. And
what this allows you to do is create all
these different patterns in those
different time frames. So even if you
see a pattern on a one minute chart, it
may play out a specific move on a one
minute chart, but there could be a
completely different pattern on a 30
minute chart. But all the candlestick
patterns and everything that we're going
to go over can be used on any market or
time frame because what you're doing is
you're reading the candlesticks. And
candlesticks represent the price
movement of that asset you're looking at
and it's essentially the raw data of
where the buyers and sellers are. And so
no matter what you're trading, it's
representing that raw data. And all
these patterns are common indicators of
what that raw data is really telling you
could happen in the market. Now, most
traders know what candlesticks are, but
almost none of them know how to actually
use them correctly. And that's why I'm
building up to the tool that I use to
confirm what really makes a candlestick
pattern a signal and not just noise to
fake you out. Now, make sure to remember
these four key points in the candlestick
because one of the tools that I'm going
to show you later is entirely based on
this data and it's extremely powerful
for helping you confirm candlestick
entries. Now, let's go over some
candlestick anatomy. The first off being
big versus small bodies and what this
means. A big body represents dominance
from either the buyers or sellers. This
green candlestick right here opening
here, moving all the way up here and
closing shows a lot of buying pressure
versus something smaller like this where
the sellers it opens up here, moves down
and closes here is small representing
not that much movement from the sellers.
This is a trade right here where I made
over $2,000. And yeah, this candlestick
right here was a really big clue to jump
in on the trade, but wasn't the overall
reason of why I took this trade. The
real confirmation came from something
else. Something that I'll show you later
that helps me confirm whether a
candlestick pattern is worth entering in
or not. The big candlesticks matter, but
only when they align with the right
signals. Now, the second most important
structure you'll see is candlesticks
with large wicks. This candlestick right
here is showing you a potential for a
reversal because the price of this
candlestick opened up here, pushed up
higher, and then sold off and closed a
tiny bit above where it was. But
essentially, what this candlestick is
telling you is that this overall price
was rejected. And so it could signal a
potential for a reversal. Same thing
with this candlestick. The only
difference is a slight difference in the
open price of the candlestick and the
close price. It's just flipped. And then
this candlestick pattern right here is
the same thing but in reverse where the
price opened up here, pushed a little
higher, sold off hard, but then that
hard sell off there was reversed and it
closed somewhere there. Again, this is
showing you a potential for a reversal
to come in the following candlesticks.
This is why knowing that data versus
just a line chart is extremely
important. Now, these big wicks are
critical for entering into potential
trades. This trade right here, this big
reversal candlestick with a huge wick
was the final confirmation to jump on
this trade that made over $1,000 in just
a few minutes. but only when they appear
in the right context. In a minute, I'm
going to show you how to tell when these
big reversal wicked candlesticks are
actually important and when they're just
making noise trying to trap you. Now,
the last one of these is when there is a
small body and equal wicks on above or
below the body of the candlestick. What
these do is they show classic
indecision. And the whole reason of this
is because for either of these three
candlestick patterns, the price
essentially opened up somewhere in the
middle of the candlestick, pushed one
direction, reversed the other direction,
and then reversed again, closing near
the middle of the candlestick. With this
one right here, it's specifically opened
and closed at the exact same price,
showing no movement. But it's really key
to know that because what this does is
it shows indecision. And these are
called dogeis. But here's the problem.
Dogeis constantly fake people out or
just get them in bad trades. So in a
minute, I'll show you how to read them
correctly and use them to your
advantage. But first, we need to talk
about multi- candlestick patterns. Now,
let's jump into the top six candlestick
patterns I've used over the years. These
are common candlestick patterns that you
will see that based on their structure
and the market psychology of what the
data is showing you commonly will play
out in a specific manner. Now the first
one of these candlestick patterns is
called the engulfing candlestick
pattern. It's just a two candlestick
pattern, but what it signifies is that
it's a reversal pattern where the chart
is coming down. And if you see this
pattern, it will signify that it's
likely that the price reverses to the
upside. The idea of how this works is
you have a bearish candlestick that is
engulfed by a bullish candlestick right
after it where the open of this
candlestick is lower than the low of the
previous candlestick and the close of it
is higher than the high of the bearish
candlestick. The whole idea is it is a
massive reversal happening where it
completely blows out the previous
candlestick. And this can happen on the
flip side for the bearish version too
where a smaller bullish candlestick is
engulfed by a big bearish candlestick.
And again, the idea is that it's a
reversal candlestick and likely the
market is going to reverse after this.
And this is a great confirmation for an
entry just like the trades I showed
earlier. But again, you don't want to
just blindly be using it by itself. The
next one of these patterns is called a
pin bar candlestick. This is where the
important of wicks comes into play. What
this can help us do is it's another
reversal candlestick pattern. But the
idea is that you have a big bullish
candlestick followed by what's called
this reversal candlestick. This large
wick is showing us that the price tried
to continue higher and was rejected.
It's showing you a flip in the momentum
of the market that this is representing.
the price was previously moving higher
and a topping pattern is going to flip
the price of the market and this
candlestick here is showing that and
followed by it to complete this pattern
is a nice bearish reversal candlestick
after this. The idea is that this is
going to reverse lower and it's a
confirmation that you can use to enter
into a trade. Same thing goes for the
bullish version where it's coming down
reversing in a big way and it's
indicating that the market could
continue higher reversing that trend
that it was in. This is how you can
start to read the market like a book.
You can start to use these patterns and
slowly build upon them connecting them
so you can eventually read a whole stock
chart clearly. This next candlestick
pattern is called a threeline strike
pattern. What it's showing you is there
is a clean methodical uptrend in the
market and then it is broken and
reversed very rapidly by this huge
engulfing candlestick that engulfs
multiple of the candlesticks before it.
It shows you a massive switch in
momentum and a massive increase in
momentum in the other direction. And so
how you can use this is again bullish or
bearish side is that the market is
switching from a slow methodical move
lower to a rapid move higher. Buyers are
really stepping in wanting to buy at
this level which is likely to continue
to push the market higher after this
pattern. Again these patterns are super
powerful but you have to stack them with
other indicators. Now that we can start
to get into some larger patterns and a
flag pattern is a key pattern that will
help us understand how to read dogeis.
And so how this pattern works is it's a
continuation pattern. The idea is the
market moves up and goes sideways. It
essentially creates a flag. The idea
with this is the market's had a really
strong move higher and it's now just
taking a breather. It's coming to a
point where it just needs to catch its
breath. It's a little overextended. And
this pattern often signifies a
continuation that it could continue
higher. That this momentum that it had
before is just taking a pause and it's
going to come back in and push the
market higher. But what will often
happen is you'll start to see dogeis
here when it flags out. And dogeis are
okay if there's a couple of them. But
once there becomes too many, you can
start to get trapped. If we flip over to
the bearish version here, it's the same
thing to the flip side where we have a
strong momentum to the downside, but
then it starts to go sideways. And the
key to knowing if this is really going
to continue or it could do what I call a
failed breakout where it attempts to
break lower and the market actually
reverses trapping people and making this
pattern cause a false signal is when you
start to get a lot of dogeis stacking
up. When you start to see the market
just sit there for too long, that's when
the momentum has really just dried up
and it's not taking a brief break. The
idea with this pattern is it has a large
momentum move and it just takes a quick
break before it continues higher. If it
starts to take too long of a break like
this, that's when you want to stay out.
That's when the dogeis can really start
to give you some insight that there is
too much indecision in the market and
it's likely to not have a clear move in
either direction that is easy to trade
and you should stay out of the market. I
used to fall for this all the time
myself. This pattern right here looks
really clean, right? But this can easily
turn into what I call a failed breakout
where the market pushes lower and then
immediately flips on you, reversing
higher. There's one key missing step
that is really good to know to tell the
difference between if it's actually
going to break out or do a fake out. And
we're almost to where we can talk about
that, but I want to first talk about a
few big picture candlestick patterns
that are really going to tie this all
together for you. The first one of those
is a pullback pattern. This is a super
simple market structure pattern, but
it'll start to connect some of these
dots for you. The whole idea with this
is here's the bearish version, which
means the market's going to reverse is
the market's coming up in a nice solid
trend higher. It pulls back and then it
pushes one more time up. But then what
happens is you'll notice we get an
engulfing candlestick pattern right
here. And what that signals is it's
putting in a lower high right here. This
swing, if you kind of just think about
it like a line chart now, is the market
made a high here, pulled back, made one
more high here, and now is pushing
lower. That high is lower than this one.
And in the big picture structure idea of
the market, that is a big reversal
signal. If you couple it with this
engulfing candlestick pattern, this
starts to become a powerful signal. As
soon as this engulfing candlestick
pattern here is formed, you can use that
as a confirmation to enter in on a trade
with the idea that the market is going
to push lower based off of that. Same
thing goes for the bullish side, but you
can see on the flip side, same thing,
but you could have a different
candlestick pattern, making this, you
know, you can even call it a double
bottom. This is how you start to look at
candlesticks and create larger picture
structures in the market that can signal
key areas that you want to pay attention
to. So, you can start to see this
pattern and the flag pattern are very
similar in a lot of ways. How do you
know when a pattern is going to either
continue or when it's going to fake you
out in the opposite direction in
reverse? Which is why in a minute we're
going to go over how do you know when
it's actually the right time to jump
into a trade versus when it's important
to stay out so you don't actually get
trapped and lose money. Now, the last
one of these is called the head and
shoulders pattern. It's a big key
reversal pattern, but again, it's really
powerful when you couple it with the
indicators that really confirm whether
an area is worth taking a trade or not.
The whole idea of how this works is it's
looking at the big picture structure of
the market. It's essentially looking at
the swings of the market where it's
making a in an uptrend. It's making
higher highs and higher lows
consistently and then all of a sudden it
switches to making lower lows and then
lower highs. What you'll start to notice
about these patterns is that they're
very simple. You do not need complex
patterns to understand what the market
is doing. And keys with this head and
shoulders pattern is on the bullish side
where this is going to signal, you know,
we're going to make a reversal to the
upside. This key is you want this final
extreme low that it makes to be strong
and then it to reverse quickly.
Essentially, it's showing you the market
got overextended, accelerated to this
side, and then buyers came in in a big
way, and pushed it to the upside. This
final pullback here, and really adding
this pullback pattern that we talked
about earlier, essentially what it's
doing is it's showing you, it's giving
you the confirmation of, okay, is this
going to just continue lower? Because,
well, it could just continue making
lower lows and lower highs here. But
once it creates this bottom here and
really starts to form this candle and
this candle, that's when you can
confidently say that, okay, it's
starting to shift. And that's how you
use these patterns to understand what
the market is going to do. And so when
it comes to trading, a lot of times you
start out thinking that I need, you
know, 10 different indicators on my
chart and all these different things
that make it easy to, you know, know
what to do because it seems like an
indicator can just tell you what to do.
But at the end of the day, if you learn
to just do some of these basic chart
analysis things, you will drastically
improve your trading. One of those is
just learning to look at the major swing
highs and swing lows of a market. It
will drastically improve your
understanding of the direction of the
overall trend. And when it comes to
actually entering in trades, the biggest
factor I always take into consideration,
no matter how good the more smaller
patterns look, is the overall big
picture of what the market is doing
because that is going to rule your trade
no matter what. It doesn't matter how
good a support level looks or a trend
line looks. If it's coming to a major
area where and your big picture analysis
of a trend is that it's overextended and
it needs to slow down, well, if you, you
know, jump in short right here and you
weren't looking at just that big
picture, you're going to be losing a lot
more trades than you want. And so, the
basics of, you know, downtrends and
uptrends are made by the market making
lower lows and lower highs where just
the swings are getting lower and lower.
An uptrend is just a flip where it's
making higher highs and higher lows. And
this really helps you. Just this basic
structure helps you stay on the right
side of the market of saying, "Okay,
well overall this thing is mainly making
lower lows and lower highs. There can be
some times where okay, it gets a little
back and forth here where it has a uh
you know right here it had actually more
of a quick uptrend before it continued
its downtrend. So that could have just
been a pullback in the major downtrend
that was taking place. And this can also
happen because what's happening is
you're at a transition period where you
are going from a downtrend where it's
making consistent lower lows and lower
highs and then all of a sudden it starts
making a higher low and then a higher
high and it shifts to an uptrend. So,
you're going to have these areas and
these are really key to start to learn
is have areas where it starts to shift
and you want to be aware of that because
that's when the trend is starting to
change. If you're either in a trade
betting that it's going to go down,
well, that's usually a signal to get
out. Or if you're looking for the market
to reverse to the upside, well, you can
take that into account for going long
and taking a reversal trade and trying
to buy the bottom of the swing. And so a
super helpful thing with identifying a
lot of the swings in the market. And
this is just going to take you time to
understand is going through and you can
use things like a trend line. And so how
I like to draw trend lines is if I just
use a quick drawing to kind of show you
before we look at the charts because no
chart really looks like this. But a lot
of the time what you want to do is you
want to essentially just match the
highs. The idea with the trend line is
you're matching it to all the main swing
highs that you're seeing. And then on
the flip side, you can also make what's
called a channel where essentially it's
both where the market doesn't do this a
lot of the time, but it can sometimes
make a channel where on the upside where
the pullbacks they will respect a
downtrend. And then on the the the swing
low side is they'll also basically be
respecting a downwards trending support
line. And this is a downwards trending
resistance line. And so what those do is
those essentially make a channel and
they make it really easy to identify
what the market is doing. Now because
the market is always changing now a
clear kind of one is actually on a
bigger time frame right now. This is the
NASDAQ futures. So how you want to draw
a trend line and start one is you'll see
here we're looking at the big swings
here and then it makes a high here and
then it starts to just trend lower. Now
you're not going to know these right
away. It takes some time and you know it
usually takes at least two swings to be
able to draw that trend line before
knowing it could bounce off of it a
third time. And so I like to at least
wait for two swings to draw it off of.
And so here there's this big swing up
here and this swing right here. And so
for me I would take a drawing tool and
start it at the swing high here and then
draw it touching this next one. And then
so here you can see the market came up
here and it didn't quite touch this if
if you put it to exactly the highs. But
so that's the big thing about any tool
or drawing tool you use in the market
with support or resistance trend lines
anything you use take it with a grain of
salt. You can have some flexibility in
it. It's not going to be okay well it
didn't touch my line exactly so I'm not
going to it it didn't count. Right?
think of it more of like a zone. This is
a big thing I do and we'll talk about in
a minute with my support or resistance
levels is I don't think of it like one
line. I think of it as an area where
okay, well, the market will come up here
somewhere and reverse lower versus this,
you know, it it's a big line. I don't
wait for it to come exactly up here. So,
if it's coming up here, I'm thinking,
okay, well, it's close and, you know, if
if a trade set up off that, then I would
take a trade off of it. And so once it
finishes, well then I'm going to adjust
based on that because I consider this to
be a pretty clear touch and a reversal.
And so going forwards again, I would
look at that and say, okay, well extend
this out and see what happens. And this
is where trend lines and everything
become very subjective is you can match
this either with the highs or you can
also drag it down here and say, well, it
kind of there's all these bodies here.
Well, if you do that, you can see that
this got a lot closer here and made a
lot more sense. And so that's where
drawing tools can be a little tricky or
drawing trend lines can be a little
tricky is it can be very subjective
because you can see here well once we
got down here and down here is what
pretty much was touching these ones as
well. And so that's kind of how trend
lines work. And so that's why we're
drawing them. My kind of rule of thumb
is take it with a grain of salt. It
doesn't count as a break of the trend
line if it, you know, breaks by one
candlestick and goes back in or it has a
wick that breaks above. A clean break of
a trend line is where the candlesticks
clearly break out here like this. And so
kind of on the flip side, what that can
look like, just to find you a quick
example here, here's another just moving
back in the chart a little bit. Here's
kind of a trend line right here I would
consider. And you can see here it's
clearly broken that. And so at that
point I would say, hey, I think that
this trend is over. The potential there
means that it's it could either go
sideways or it could reverse to the
upside. And so from that point, you
know, you would use whatever other
factors you're using an analysis like
support zone here. I already have drawn
on the chart or just looking at the big
picture. Where are the big swings uh in
the market and kind of what's been going
on? So at that point, it looks like
okay, yeah, it's kind of bouncing and I
would look for, you know, kind of a move
off of that. And so when it comes to
practically using trend lines, they're
going to be broken pretty quickly a lot
of the time. And a good example was
actually this morning in gold where on a
actually a one minute chart here is it
had a really nice bottom here and a
trend line up. And so the market just
followed this for a while until it
eventually broke. And so you can have
multiple types of trend lines where
they're really sharp here and and just
kind of very fastpaced or like that
bigger picture downtrend one that we're
looking at. And even gold actually has
one going on right now too is zooming
out to more of a bigger picture
15-minute chart. As you can see here,
it's got this, you know, it made a a
larger swing high right here, kind of a
double top, and then it's had two clear
swings here. And then the third one I
think pretty clearly bounced off of
that. And so another example here is on
the flip side. You can see on the bottom
end I've drawn a swing off of these two.
And then there's this third one right
here. And so it looks like it's clearly
starting to bounce there. Find some
support. And so that's how you can start
to use these as clearly predicting where
the market could slow down and reverse.
Now, one last one is it I call it a
spike in channel or a spike in trend
where uh a lot of times in a beginning
of a move the market right here you can
see it does a quick spike where it just
moves very rapidly in one direction and
then it starts to slow down into more of
a methodical trend. Now, this one's
still pretty tight here, but you can
have it essentially on the flip side too
on a on an uptrend where it goes up and
then it starts to go into more of a
healthier trend. The market has a lot of
different types of trends where you know
they're unhealthy moves like this where
they're likely to have a pullback or
consolidation at some point or more
healthier moves where you know like this
if we zoom out where you know it it's
slowly moving back and forth and that's
more of a rangebound move and when it
comes to trading futures I've always
found it be to be very important to
stick to when there's more volatility in
the market because trading in, you know,
a choppy market. This is the NASDAQ
yesterday on a five-minute chart. This
is the whole day of trading basically
and this is the first kind of two hours
and you can see it just sat here and did
nothing. And so that's times where you
kind of want to stay out and not watch
the market too much and save your money
for a day where you have more volatility
like this where there's more moves that
are more tradable. And so this is where
timeframes are really important to pay
attention to. You can trade whatever
time frame you want, but when it comes
to futures, I highly recommend sticking
to entering your trades on either a one
minute chart or a five minute chart. And
then bigger picture, you can look at I
like to look at a 15-inute chart or a 30
minute chart for kind of understanding
the broader picture of what the market's
doing, drawing these kind of bigger
swing moves. And that really helps you
understand the big picture of what's
going on because you can easily see,
okay, based on just the swings of the
market right here in gold that it's
pretty back and forth right now. It's
kind of in this downwards tightening
wedge that's going on. But just looking
at this and not really analyzing it too
much, you can think that, okay, well,
just based on what it's been doing, it's
kind of been going back and forth with
some moves in between. And so when it
makes this move, well, it's probably
likely to move back up because the
market likes to just repeat what it's
doing most of the time until obviously
the trend kind of shifts. But when it's
in this kind of back and forth mode,
going into a larger time frame to see
that and understand that is really
important because then you can go into a
one minute like this or a 5m minute and
enter your trades more accurately near
the lows of that swing and you know you
could enter in right here betting that
the market was going to go up, capture
that swing and you could get something
like four times your risk in your
profits. And so that's why time frames
are really important and especially day
trading and intraday trading because
when it comes to futures intraday margin
is very very powerful and the real
reason why I think it's good to trade
futures if you're trying to swing trade
futures I think there's other better
safer assets to do that but when it
comes to day trading futures are really
really powerful because of the low
margin requirement that some brokers
have. And so that's what I use when it
comes to trading. I use a 1 minute and a
5 minute to enter and a 15 and a 30 to
analyze my charts. And that's the whole
idea of technical analysis is just using
the basic structure of the market. Now
where you can get in trouble is
overanalyzing. And that's why I like to
stick to where it's just super clear and
really obvious what's going on and
staying out of insanely choppy times
like this. The market the last couple
days here you can see these are the
opening days and then this is kind of
the overnight movement. Every day here
the the NASDAQ here has pretty much just
done nothing. There's times in the
market where you'll have movements that
are just terrible for trading. Every
strategy has market conditions that are
crappy. My strategy is more of a
reversal strategy of taking trades off
of either big trend lines and looking
for a move down or off of, you know,
good support lines and looking for moves
up off of those. But any time that the
market is just sitting here chopping
like this and you can even go to a one
minute chart. Today had some good
movement for the first time. But if I
zoom in on this day, you can see it's
just back and forth. If you zoom in, it
looks like maybe there's some good
movement. But big picture again, there's
really really little movement to
capture. Or continuation markets are
terrible when the market is in more of a
rangebound or reversal volatile market.
And so that's why it's really important
for you to understand what markets are
good to trade in and what aren't. And
the biggest one again is choppy markets
and just learning to understand and
read, okay, well, when is there a big
movement and volatility? That's when you
want to start paying attention and
looking for potential trades. It doesn't
have to be necessarily looking for
reversals. It could be looking for
continuations if you think the trend is
really strong. Again, that's why you
look at the big picture and say, "Okay,
what do I think is happening?" And if we
look at and analyze this, well, the
market was in a big downtrend and then
it started to have this support level.
Well, I think when it breaks this
support level, it's had all this
consolidation, which is really healthy
for the market. And so, once it breaks,
it's very likely to have a large move in
that direction because it's broken this
support level. It's not overextended.
it's unlikely to fake lower and continue
higher because also looking to the left
side of the chart, there isn't great
support levels to look at. It had a kind
of a pretty strong trend up. And so big
picture, this trend could be reversing
and having a pullback before, you know,
it it does whatever it's going to do
next. And that's where if you, you know,
wondered what this would be doing next
on a bigger picture, you could zoom out
even more to, let's say, like a
60-minute chart or even a daily chart.
And that's where, you know, ignore all
the random little drawing time frames
because those are incorrect. We're on a
daily chart right now. But, you know,
looking at a daily chart, this is where
I would think, okay, we're in a clear
big uptrend. You know, we might be
having a bit of a pullback here, but I'm
assuming we're in an uptrend until we
have a clear like pullback and a double
top and, you know, something's starting
to fail here. And that's where time
frames are really important to
understand of just because on a daily
chart right here the NASDAQ is in an
uptrend doesn't mean that if I go to a
you know a 5minut chart or a one minute
chart I'm not going to be looking for a
short on a shorter period time frame.
You can still be looking for shorts and
longs. It just m depends on what time
frame you're looking at and what those
time frames are telling you about the
market. And so what's really important
and helpful is understanding just basic
candlestick patterns. What these will do
for you is once you kind of understand
how to read markets, you don't really
need these, but it's a good cheat sheet
when you're first starting because if we
look at this, like here is a descending
triangle and it's basically saying,
okay, the market has a horizontal
support with a downwards trend line and
the trend into it was a downtrend. And
so once it breaks this to the downside,
this support, it's saying it's likely to
continue lower. And if we look at our
NASDAQ chart, well, you can see we
pretty much had a downwards descending
triangle right here where it had that
support level and then a downwards trend
line. And once it broke that, it had a
really big move lower. And so that's a
really good way to use these and match
them up with what's going on to help you
understand when you're starting to learn
these as a beginner. And so when it
comes to actual candlestick patterns as
well, these can really help you break
down some smaller patterns of what could
potentially be happening right at these
inflection points. Now these are all
reversal patterns. Once you kind of
understand what they mean is it really
makes a lot of sense. And so for
instance here, this one, it's a V
reversal because you have a trend coming
down quickly and then you have a hammer
candlestick pattern where the market
essentially just goes like this in that
one candlestick and then big picture it
continues higher. This candlestick
pattern essentially on a smaller time
frame, what I'm drawing here is it
essentially just makes a double top. And
a double top is a larger bigger picture
structure reversal pattern. And these
ones right here is they are a momentum
switch where the market is going down in
this case really methodically and starts
to slow down and you have a massive
switch in momentum. And so going through
this will really help you understand how
these can work. And another one is
essentially consolidation where the
market either here it has it in a form
of just a dogee or here it has it in the
form of multiple candlesticks where it
has a downtrend it starts to just go
sideways and then it moves up. So let's
talk about the theory of supply and
demand first. And so if we're looking at
just like let's say a market of gold,
well as the price of gold is really low,
there's going to be a low supply of it
because there's not that many people
wanting to sell it. Why would I sell,
you know, this gold bar that I think is
valuable for a really low amount of
money? But as the price gets really
high, more and more people are going to
think, well, hey, I want to sell my bar
of gold because I can get a lot of money
for it because the price of it is really
high. I'm getting a lot of value. But
then on the flip side, for demand, well,
if something's really, really expensive,
like a bar of gold, I'm not going to
want it because I don't want to pay that
much money for something I think I can
get for a lesser value later. And so as
time goes on and as the price goes down,
demand actually increases. And so you
have imbalances where supply can be
really high, but no one wants to
actually buy it because it's overvalued
or times where demand is really high,
but nobody wants to sell it because they
don't want to sell it for dirt cheap.
And so in the middle here, that's where
you have more of an equilibrium where
buyers and sellers meet. And so when it
comes to actually trading, what you can
have is and what you create is supply
and demand zones. based on stuff that
we'll talk about in a minute of how you
identify these. But based on past
observations, you can start to create
these and know that okay, well, when the
price comes down to this demand zone,
it's likely that it's oversold, that the
price is so cheap that there's likely to
be a high demand, which will over time
increase the price because more and more
people want to buy it. And so the supply
actually starts to dry up. And so if
there's a finite amount of something,
the price is going to go up over time as
more and more people buy it and more and
more people want it. But eventually it's
going to get to a point where it's at a
price where more people want to start to
sell it because they can get a really
high amount of money for it. And so the
price will go down. And so quite often
you'll hit these extreme areas and have
strong moves off of them and then you'll
get into that more middle ground between
the two where it has that equilibrium
and it'll have more of a choppy market.
And so this is why when you look at a
stock chart, it's important to
understand that these extremes are the
important part to pay attention to
because you'll likely have the market
bounce off these zones quickly and like
I said, chop around in the middle and
then it will once it comes up to a
level, you have that potential to
reverse off of it. And so that's how you
want to look at trading these levels.
And so this is how I like to use them
for trading is I like to watch for key
areas where I think that the market
might find a supply or demand and it's
likely to reverse off of the supply and
demand zone and then you can capture a
nice swing off of that. In this trade
right here, the market came down to this
demand zone down here and I bought, went
long and captured a move up and made
about $1,500 on this trade. And then as
it came up to where I thought there was
another supply zone, I got out of the
trade because it's likely that it
reverses off that zone and I wanted to
get out of my profitable trade and move
on with my day. Now, this is horizontal
supply and demand zones. What you can
actually have is trending supply and
demand zones where the market is moving
down slowly and it continues to move
lower over time. But what you get is it
starts to bounce off of supply and
demand zones as it creates those. And so
you can start to take trades as it tests
these levels. Another way to do this is
it can actually be created with more
trend lines. And so every time it comes
up to that trend line, you can think of
it as a supply zone. It's just more
horizontal. A good example of this is a
trade I took recently where the market
had a demand trend level down here that
I wanted to take a trade off of. And so
it bounced around, moved up higher, and
then sold off to that level to where I
thought, okay, it's likely that the
market starts to slow down here. Waited
for a setup that I like. a few key
patterns that I look for every time that
I'll talk about in a little while to
enter in, confirm the trade, and then I
waited for it to play out, and it
eventually played out, moving up to the
higher end of the range, and I was able
to get out for a clean $1,200 trade
pretty quickly. And so, that's how I use
supply and demand because it's so
powerful to simplify trading. There's so
many indicators and concepts when it
comes to trading and I always found the
best way is to focus on just one or two
things and supply and demand really
change that around for me. So I want to
talk to you about the key concepts that
I use every time I draw supply and
demand zone so I know that it's actually
powerful and it's likely that the market
actually reverses off of it. Otherwise,
it's so easy going into our first
concept. It's so easy to draw supply
levels everywhere and not know which
ones are going to hold and which ones
are going to break. And so for me, the
first biggest thing is not looking at
those levels in the middle of the range.
I like to stick to then at an extreme of
that supply and demand in the market
versus being in that middle of that area
and you could have a chop and just not
have something that's worth taking a
trade. And so that's the first key
concept is stick to extremes in the
market. I always find that for my
trades, even though I have a, you know,
a three to fivestep checklist I look for
every time I enter into a trade, it
doesn't matter if everything on a one
minute chart is aligning up perfectly
and it looks like it's going to have a
great trade. If the big picture isn't
aligned and saying like, hey, yeah, I
think that we could bounce to the upside
or that we're at a extreme where the
overall price is likely to have a
snapback, then there's no trade. This is
the most important thing when it comes
to executing and confirming my trades is
things being at an extreme and also the
big picture being aligned with what I
think is going to happen. Now, when it
comes to drawing these zones, what I
like to do is I like to see at a minimum
multiple touches. So, in terms of here,
there's this swing right here and then
there's these two touches right here.
And so, what I did was I said, "Okay,
hey, I think you know when the market
was trending nearly where it is right
now with that bounce we just saw, I go
back multiple this is me going back
almost a month in data to find this
level." And so I go based off of okay,
we have the extreme down here and then
we've also got a couple of bounces here.
It looks like we kind of had a head and
shoulders here, but essentially there's
some chop in here and some bounces. And
so that's I think okay, it's you know
why I draw a zone and then I'm just
going to drag it across here to where
essentially the current price is. And as
the market came down here, I said,
"Okay, I think it's likely we bounce off
of here." and then it gets a nice really
clean double bottom and then I go into a
smaller time frame and look to see if
there's a nice setup right here and I
can catch a big swing higher. And so the
reason why I draw zones instead of very
specific lines for my horizontal levels
is because it's a supply and demand
zone. You don't know where exactly it's
going to bounce. It's going to bounce
somewhere in this area. Every time the
market comes down and tests a level,
things are going to slightly change.
Maybe the market will come down here and
barely test it here because in this
instance, when it's coming down to this
level, well, there's some news out or
for some reason a lot of people want to
buy it now and it's going to bounce way
sooner or it pushes further down. people
are less interested in buying it until
it gets to an even deeper extreme and
then that imbalance happens and people
swoop in, pick it up quickly and then it
rockets up. And so that's why you can
see there's a big rocket in this case.
And so that leads into our next concept
is when there is a massive move off of a
level, I like to key into that as well
because if there is really aggressive
buying or selling, it means that a lot
of people came in in the buying side,
there was a lot of demand. And so it
makes it more likely that when it comes
back in the future, people are going to
want to buy it. or on the flip side, if
there's a big selling, it makes it more
likely that people are going to want to
sell when it comes up to this area. Now,
most of the time, I like to just look at
the last few days for a lot of my levels
because that's the most recent price
action, and it's more likely that
something's going to happen based off of
that. If you zoom really far out and you
have a level all the way from back here,
when the market touches that again
months later, I find that a lot of the
time something has changed at that
point. And if it comes all the way down
here, I'm going to look for that to
potentially break. Now, let's talk about
some keys of how do you know to the best
of your judgment? because you never
truly know and can never truly confirm
if a supply or demand level is going to
hold is it's how the market comes into
that level. And so you have multiple
trends where either you have a very
fastpaced extreme aggressive move or you
have a healthy trend with methodical
pullbacks where it sometimes even breaks
the trend, moves around, chops, touches
the zone and then continues to chop a
little bit. But essentially how I see it
is when the market has a very fastpaced
move like this, it's more likely to
bounce at a zone just like this move
right here. And the reason why is
because it's an unhealthy move. The
market when it just has an unhealthy
move in general, even if there isn't a
supply or demand zone, it needs some
kind of pullback to create that
equilibrium. And when it hits that
extreme of this supply and demand theory
graph, there's going to be so much
supply in the market, if we quickly go
back to the concept here, is because if
it shoots down so fast, there's some
crazy momentum pushing it and pushing
and forcing price to be so cheap down
here. But at some point when it gets so
cheap, people are going to start buying
it and sellers are going to eventually
start to dry up and you will have what
is called a Vbottom. And so you have
that right here. In this case, it
actually did almost a double Vbottom
where it came down, spiked, supply kind
of push it down lower one more time, and
then as it hit here again, people came
in and said, "No, this is a amazing
price." And it rockets up from there.
And so this is how a volatile market
works because supply and demand is all
over the place and that is really really
good for trading when a a and for likely
that a level will hold. Now, sometimes
you'll have it to where it just blows
through a level, and those are easy to
avoid. And that's why one thing is,
we'll get to my checklist in a minute of
why you have a reasons that you look out
for to jump in and buy in an area like
this. You don't just blindly say, "Hey,
I'm going to put in a limit order down
here, a buy order that when this price
comes down here, if it does, I just want
to get long no matter what it looks like
because I think it's likely to go up."
Well, that's not always true because
supply can be so powerful that it blows
right through this level and you have to
look at the next level. And so those
unhealthy trends when they do start to
lose a little momentum, I find it's
likely that it reverses and those are
the best trades. Now, when a zone is
more likely to break is if maybe we can
find a quick one here is this was a
pretty good zone right here. You know,
this was a zone I was watching for a
while. We had multiple touches up here.
You could even drag it down and take
this swing. This is a clear swing where
it came up to that zone, bounced off. We
had a lot of chop up here and eventually
sold off. And when the market came up
here again, well, I'm looking at the big
picture. And so the big picture is we've
come down, sold off, there was a big
news that caused a spike. The whole time
after that news, the market was just
kind of chopping back and forth. And
well, pattern-wise, this is a this is a
bull flag right here. And if you look at
the lows, they're essentially getting
higher and higher. Every time after the
first couple times, the market would
make a push up here. The swing low would
get higher and higher. And what that
means is people are coming in and buying
the extremes that where it gets pushes
to the downside sooner and sooner. And
so as it starts to in my eyes has a
healthy move up here where there's moves
with ups and pullbacks and it starts to
kind of sit here and you know it kind of
sat here and chopped around for a while
and it sold off and then it comes up
here and starts to sit here again. To
me, that makes it way more likely that
it continues higher. And this is
actually one of the trades we looked at
a minute ago that I just quickly showed.
This is where that trend line of
trending supply and demand worked out as
well. You can also see as the moves move
up, it creates those with the swings.
And so this is the cleanest one right
here where it popped up, sold off a
little. And so you could say, well, this
is a micro supply level. Came back down
to here, broke that, hit another supply
level. It was kind of the highs at this
point. Big area where it's likely to
sell off, sold off. And then at this
point, you have multiple touches here to
where I drew this trend line. This was
actually before market opens where it
came up and it hit this demand trend
line and also hit this previous say
supply level that turned into a demand
level. So that's the interesting thing
as well is levels when they're broken
can flip. And so in this case, and this
happens all the time where you have a
high and then the market breaks that and
it comes back and tests that high. And
you can see this all over the market. If
you just zoom out and kind of look, you
can see here's another concept of it
happening where the market came up here,
put in a high, kind of sold off a little
bit, broke above that, and then if you
pretty much just draw these highs, it
came up, bounced off of it, and made an
attempt to keep going higher before the
market started selling off rest of this
day. And so that's where when I'm
looking at the market come up into a
level in a healthy way into either a
supply or demand level, I think it's
more likely to break that zone and I
will avoid betting to the downside. And
so even though the market came up to
this extreme level that I was watching
and instead of betting to the downside,
I said, "Okay, I'm not betting to the
downside. I'm just going to sit out on
that potential trade." and I looked to
take this long right here, betting that
the market was going to break and go
higher. Okay, so first off, some basics
about scalping. Scalping, the whole idea
is you are taking small trades on a
small timeframe chart. I enter in trades
on generally a one minute chart and I'm
essentially looking for just capturing
like a move from here to here. I'm not
looking for a massive swing in the
market. If we zoom all the way out, I'm
not looking for a huge move over
multiple days. You're going into a small
time frame chart and looking for a quick
move to happen. The trades are generally
really short in length. You can see
here, this one I entered in on about,
you know, 7:46
my time and I ended up getting out about
here, which was 7:48. So, it literally
took me like 10 or 15 minutes. They're
very fast. Sometimes they can be long
just if depending on the market, but
generally if there's good movement,
you're going to be in and out of a trade
very quickly. But the whole idea of this
is think about yourself as like a sniper
in the army. You are sitting there
patiently waiting for the perfect shot
or trade setup to happen. I took this
trade this morning and I haven't taken a
trade all week. I haven't taken a trade.
If we zoom out to a larger time frame
chart, here's 1 day, 2 day, 3 day, 4
day. It's currently Thursday. I didn't
take a trade this day, this day, or this
day. And so, it's a lot of waiting. But
the idea is you're waiting for that
perfect setup or almost perfect setup to
happen. And then when you jump in, you
can make a lot of money once you
sidestep. A lot of mistakes that people
do and that I did a lot when I first
started out too is trying to capture
every move is trying to capture this
move and then capture this move. And
it's impossible to capture every single
move in the market. Instead, I found it
to be way more consistently profitable
is to wait something like all week for a
really clean setup. And then the money
you make comes from sizing up. It's easy
to get stuck in that trap of, "Oh, well,
if I make a $100 every trade, well, to
make $1,000 this week, I need to make 10
trades." And taking 10 profitable trades
without any losers is really hard to do.
Trading is really hard at the end of the
day. And so, I find it way easier to be
super patient during the whole week. And
once a, you know, in a way a perfect
setup shows up, that's when you can jump
in because a lot of the time if you look
at it, you know, the rest of the day
once this move happened, the market's
just choppy and it's really hard to
trade. There is movement in here that
you could theoretically make money off
of, but that's really hard to do
consistently over time. Another big
issue that I had in the beginning was
going for a small amount of money with
my trades is going for, let's say, $50
and I'm risking $100. What this does is
it gives you a negative riskreward
ratio. And so what you want to do is
flip that. And so I found it to be way
more consistently profitable to have
something like a 1:2 or 1:3 riskreward
ratio where I'm risking let's say $100
to make 200 or 300. And so I find that
extremely important to do a mistake I
did that I highly recommend you not
doing. Trading when you first start out,
you really want to jump in and make a
lot of money, but that comes with time.
Instead, focus on the patterns and
consistently trying to execute something
over time. The process is the most
important part. It takes a long time to
get to the size I am at and to be able
to make an actual lot of money from
trading. Okay. So, what I want to do now
is go through my trade entry checklist
for you in a very structured way so you
can then know exactly what I'm looking
for. And then we can go into some real
examples so you can see what it's like
in real time. because on paper it's a
lot different than when you're actually
looking at a chart, you know, because at
the end of the day, you know, the charts
are all over the place. No trade looks
the exact same. And so the hard part is
to be able to, you know, take something
like a simple entry checklist and
consistently
use that same thing for every trade. And
so the whole idea behind my strategy and
what really helped me simplify things is
I literally only look for reversal
trades. I only look for spots where I
think the market is going to reverse. I
look for a trend to move into that
level. I look for a couple steps we're
about to go through. And then I look to
enter in and take a short off of that
level and capture a move down that the
market has generally in the first 50 to
30 minutes in the morning. And so the
first thing that needs to happen for
that is drawing and marking off those
key support and resistance zones. And
generally I do that from a 15 or 30
minute chart. Most of the time it's from
a 15-inute chart. And then for those
zones I like to have you know at least
two major swings. Again, make sure to
check out that other video with those
key steps, but I went through a lot of
them in this one already, and it's
important to stick to the extremes of
those zones and levels. That other video
will go a lot more through that. But,
so, step one is needing that big picture
reversal zone. It's not worth it to get
bogged down in all the little moves that
the market's having. stick to the
extremes because at the extremes you're
more likely to have a larger snap and a
clean move that's easy to profit from.
Now, step two is the second big key. And
so, these go in priority of importance.
Step one is the most important thing. If
you don't have a clean zone to reverse
off of, there's no trade. Step two is
analyzing that trend. If it's not clear
and you don't have a good understanding
of the trend, do not take the trade. I
have taken so many trades where I wasn't
quite sure and they always end up
losing. It's hard to be patient, but
entering in a trade only when you're the
most confident is going to increase your
profitability a lot. And so I generally
enter in on a one minute chart,
sometimes a five-minute chart, but I
really have been sticking to a one
minute chart these days. Simpler is
always better. There needs to be a clear
trend shift. A lot of what that means is
just some of those basics we were
talking about is there's a downtrend and
you know it's clearly broken and there's
you know it's starting to make higher
highs and higher lows. Another thing
it's not complicated but again it's
extremely important. It needs to be
clear that there is something like a big
flush. the trend is clearly starting to
either reverse or it's overextended and
likely to have a volatile snapback.
Those need to be in place. I've taken
trades sometimes where, you know, I if
we cut that out here and you look at
this right here where the market was
having a downtrend right here and it's
starting to slow down and it looks like
this is making a higher high here and a
higher low. But if you jump in a trade
too early without enough confirmation or
without a nice snap like this where it
really shows the overextension of the
market, well, you would have jumped in a
trade here betting to the upside and it
would have knocked you out at a loss.
And that's the hard part about trading
is waiting for that really solid
confirmation. And so step three, we
haven't really gone over this stuff as
much. So this is a lot of the really
important part of okay when do you
finally confirm of when to enter and
when you know what are the final
confirmations and so what we've been
doing a lot of the time is looking at
the big picture now how do we look at
the smaller picture and some of the
micro patterns and actually know when to
enter and so you know kind of a huge
important part of step three here is
like we talked about no choppiness in
the market you do not want to be
entering in when the market is like
this. Now on this day there is a little
bit more volatility but you know again
if I go back to the day before extreme
choppiness do not enter in that. It's
hard to be patient but you have to learn
to do that. If you can't learn to be
patient you're not going to be a
consistently profitable trader. I can
guarantee it. Now, some of the clean,
consistent patterns I like to look for
are either, you know, a double bottom
and just buying right there as it breaks
the high because this double bottom is
nice confirmation. The market has
essentially right here with the double
bottom. That's to me showing that the
market is if it's in a downtrend, it's
going to make a new low. But if it makes
a double bottom and starts to make a new
high, that's a good enough confirmation
that the micro trend is starting to
shift. Again, remember this is stacking
on top of that. It's already at a clear
support zone and the bigger picture is
aligning that it's in an area that it's
going to reverse. Another huge pattern I
like is actually a head and shoulders
pattern. And really all this pattern is
if you look at it is it's just the
basics of the swings of showing you that
oh it's now making it's from going from
higher highs and higher lows to making
uh you know a lower low and a lower high
and that's a good signal that it's going
to start going down. Now the reality of
this can look a little different.
Sometimes it's not going to perfectly
make a double bottom here. It'll
sometimes make a higher low and then a
lower low. That's actually generally a
better signal. If this low breaks this
low, it's just sooner showing you that
it's there's weakness in the market.
Really, that's all these swings are
telling you is, okay, if it can't make a
new high here, that's weakness. If it
makes a new low here and breaks this
previous one, that's weakness. If this
low here starts to sell off sooner,
that's weakness. And that's what you
want. if you're betting that the
market's going to go lower. And on the
flip side, it's the exact same thing.
And there's some other key patterns here
I won't go over right now, but this
sheet is part of a free 14page PDF guide
with a ton of these different patterns
and kind of key importances to the
pattern that you can download for free.
I'll leave a QR code on the screen or a
link in the description of this video
that you can find it at. Now the next
last thing here is the candlestick
confirmation. This is basically okay I
am about to enter into the trade. This
is the last signal that I need to look
for. And this is now you're starting to
dive into the actual candlesticks.
You're getting smaller and smaller as
you go through this checklist. And what
I like to see these are some three
patterns that I like to see. Either um
really strong candlestick strength in
the reversal direction. I'm looking for
an engulfing candlestick pattern or a
threeline strike pattern. And so the
threeline strike pattern is essentially
if you're in an uptrend here is
basically it's showing you there's
strength strength and then all of a
sudden there's a massive move. And so
what this massive move tells you is that
it's hit that point where you know all
these other things are stacking. This is
essentially think of this swing right
here as the lower high in your head and
shoulders pattern. And so what this is
showing you is okay there is a a lot of
bearishness and strength to the downside
as this lower high is forming of the
head larger head and shoulders picture.
And so from there, that's when I would
enter in at the close of this
candlestick and bet that we go down and
then it will theoretically, if it plays
out how you want, it'll start a
downtrend. And so again, this is another
section of that PDF. And then lastly,
entering in the trade, a few key things
that are very important is, again, we
went over this a little bit in the
beginning, stick to that 1:2, 1:3
riskreward ratio. In the beginning, I
suggest going for a fixed riskreward
ratio where you enter in here, let's
say, betting that the market's going to
go up and you're going to take a profit
at, let's say this is two times your
risk. And so your risk would be down
here. And so you would, let's say, lose
$100 if it went all the way down here.
And you would make $200 if it gets all
the way up here. And you don't mess with
it because maybe you go break even. you
move your stop to break even to where
you lose zero on the trade as the market
moves, let's say, up here. But don't
move your profit target away. Try not to
move your stop too much because when
you're starting out, once you're in a
trade, there's a lot more emotions. And
knowing how to adjust and deal with that
in real time and read the market
properly and not have your emotions
control you is really hard. And it's
likely that you, you know, get out here
early because you're scared or nervous
or greedy and in reality the market was
just having a little bit of a pullback
and then it's going to keep going
higher. And so I highly suggest just
sticking to a fixed profit target and
then over time adding that flexibility
in. Another huge mistake a lot of
beginners do is once you have your stop
loss, do not move it further away.
You're increasing your risk on the
trade. Don't get married to one specific
trade because we have no idea what the
market is going to do. No matter how
perfect your entry looks, the market
could just do a little bit of bounce and
just continue lower. Do not increase
your risk. Just take the loss. Get used
to losses. I have something like a 40%
win rate, 50% win rate. But because I
have that profitable riskreward ratio
that's in my favor, it plays out in the
long run. Same thing with this is kind
of going with those. Plan your exits
before you enter. Do not jump in the
trade and not know where you're going to
jump out with your profit target or your
stop-loss because they're going to
change when you're in the trade. You're
going to make different adjustments
based on the market and how your trade
is going. And instead, what you want to
do is have a plan before you enter enter
the trade so you can stick to that
consistently. Okay. Okay, so now I want
to jump into some real examples here so
this can really be solidified for you. I
want to talk about a couple of actually
really important factors for the
strategy and entering into these that I
just forgot to talk about and then as
well is go through kind of these real
examples because the market's never the
same. No trade is the same, but these
are really important to help solidify
and also to show you that I'm looking
for the exact same pattern every day
that I really just sit here and look for
the same thing. It's boring, but it
works. And so to go through that list,
the first thing I do every morning is I
actually zoom out to a 15-minute chart.
Um the market opened like up like this
this morning where it was um clearly we
had a lot of volatility the day before.
And so what I was looking at for here
was the highs here. Those are really far
away. So unlikely we're going to touch
those, but I was looking at, okay, here
is the low from yesterday. That's
important to look at. And if we get far
enough down, like we I talked about
earlier, is that gap was important to
look at as well. And then I just go into
a smaller time frame chart and
essentially wait for the market to open.
And now a big key actually is if I go
back in this recording is there's these
two red lines right here. And so what
I've realized over time is so I'm
trading the S&P 500 futures and the
NASDAQ futures. And so they open up at
7:30 my time and I've realized that over
time is that 15 minutes and 30 minutes
after those markets open are times where
it's likely to reverse. So today either
it comes down here and and hits and
reverses or it continues a bit lower or
chops here for a bit and then reverses
at that 8:00 time which is 30 minutes.
So technically it would be 9:45 and
10:00 a.m. Eastern Standard Time. And so
and so that's really those timings that
I look for every morning. And of course
I need that to align up with those other
potential factors we're looking at. And
so today, what that was going into this
was, you know, we've already talked
about this downtrend a lot and then this
flush lower we had and then you can see
it started to slow down here. We had
some choppy candles and then we had a
big bullish candlestick and it starts to
come into that timing window at 15
minutes after the open where essentially
I'm what I'm looking for there is a
flush at the open and it to slow down
here and potentially reverse and that to
align up with factors that are showing
that the market will reverse and you
know having this support zone here and
then having this downtrend was a huge
factor in that. And then the last thing
is going into looking for those
candlestick patterns to enter in on like
a double bottom or a head and shoulders
pattern. Now, this didn't have either of
those. What this had instead was a
higher low where the market comes down
here, puts in a bottom, and then makes a
higher low and it continues higher. And
so, this is okay to enter in sometimes
because the market's moving so quickly,
and that's the only signal it will give.
Other times I like to wait for a more
cleaner double bottom pullback, but in
this case I was comfortable jumping in
long on this as it essentially broke
this higher low here. And so you can see
I put in essentially a buy stop order
right here above this high. Once it
essentially breaks this swing high here,
I'm going to get in on a long and I'm
going to bet to the upside. And then my
stop is below this swing right here. And
so I'm risking about $1,500 on the
trade. And I'm looking for roughly about
two or 3x. And so that's what, you know,
I'd like to see on the trade. But
obviously, as the trade plays out, I'm
looking for areas where it might slow
down. But this trade, you can see
zooming through this footage is it
happened very, very quickly. Is it I
didn't really have any pullbacks that
went against me. it kind of just shot up
right away. And so in that case, what I
did is I elected to get out pretty
quickly. I was going to get out at 4x my
risk at with a limit order if it went
all the way up there. But if it started
to slow down at this resistance zone I
had drawn, I would also just get out on
a trailing stop. And so there I
essentially got out on it, made a little
bit of pullback, and I got out right
there for pretty much $4,500 in pretty
much 10 to 15 minutes. And so to show
you another example of this, just to
show you how repeatable this is, but
also these are trades I've took and
where I've waited for a couple of days,
right? It's not showing up perfectly
every time, but this is a perfect
example again with a couple of different
nuances to it. And so, first off, every
day, you know, I come in and okay, these
are the levels I'm looking for. There's
a a big bottom here with another higher
low. And so my thought is, okay, well,
if the market comes down here, I want to
look for a bounce. And also, there's a
little resistance level here. And so
once I draw those, I go into, you know,
a smaller time frame chart. I draw those
red lines of those keys where uh 15
minutes and 30 minutes after the open
that I want to see a reversal. And then
essentially as it comes into that
reversal timing, just like this last
trade, is what is the volatility going
into this? And so on this day, there's
good movement. Again, these are
cherrypicked days in the sense of I'm
only taking trades on days where it's
good. You're not going to see movement
like this every day, but it's there's no
point in showing you, you know,
recordings of me just sitting there not
taking a trade, right? And so those days
I'm just sitting there and, you know, I
sit there for 30 minutes and I move on
with the day. But days like this where
there's clearly movement in the market
and what I'm looking at is right here.
You can see I literally draw it exactly
how I want in the recording. I'm trying
to visualize, okay, we're in a downtrend
here. That downtrend has broken with
this trend shift right here in this
candlestick. What I want to see is if we
make a pullback here and then that would
signal essentially making a higher low
pattern which would then I would like to
enter in once it broke this previous
high and I would capture a swing up
ideally to the market open. Huge thing
about these swings and these flush moves
I've noticed is it pretty much the easy
money and the easy move is when it
reverses that move back. It has a big
move down here and then I just I
essentially want to just target this
move back. Now it could continue higher
and now that I'm a little more seasoned
with managing these trades, I can try
and hold on, but sometimes I'll just
close out because I think no, that's the
easy money. I don't think there's good
potential to continue higher reading the
big picture. That's where the experience
comes into play. But this is essentially
me being like, okay, that's what I'm
looking for today. And so it's hard
sitting and waiting through this move
because the feeling is, well, what if it
just shoots up and I miss it? That
happens. But I'm risking, you know, so
much money here that I don't need to be
in a trade very often. I could take one
of these a week and if I won every time
because of how patient I was for a good
setup, I would still be making like 20K
a month. And so trying to keep that in
mind to help me be patient is really
good. And so the market here, if we
watch this, it made a pullback here. And
so I'm planning that I'm going to put my
stop loss below this candlestick here if
it ends up being really bullish. And
then I'm going to enter in as it breaks
above this swing because again that's a
confirmation that it's making a higher
high. And so I I slightly missed it
there, but then I entered in and put an
order, jumped in essentially as it broke
that, put my stop loss where I had
planned and I'm looking for two or 3x in
profit. And so essentially at that
point, I'm not going to go into managing
too much here, but I moved to break even
essentially once it got to the market
open where I see a potential for it to
reverse, but I didn't want to close out
there because I still like the potential
to go higher. And then from there, I
just managed with the swing and the
movement of the market, eventually
getting out at about 2.5 times my risk
for about $4,500 again in pretty much 15
minutes. and then I just move on with my
day and I'm done trading. And so what I
want to do is I want to walk you through
three different trades over the years of
scaling up from a smaller account to a
larger account. You're going to have
different steps along the way at
different account sizes of how you
manage your trades, how you enter in.
And so it's going to be really crucial
for you as a growing trader to watch how
I trade and enter on each one of these
trade setups we're about to go through.
Now, don't forget to get that 90-day
trader road map in the description of
this video. It's going to have a ton of
those helpful links that we talked
about, but also a ton of stepby-step
helpful information that we just haven't
gone over in this video that you are
really going to want to be paying
attention to as you go through this
process of figuring out your strategy.
Even if you don't use my strategy, but
figuring out your strategy, figuring out
how to become consistently profitable
with that strategy and just consistently
execute the strategy. That is the
hardest part about trading is getting
consistent. So, let's start out with the
first phase here. what you should be
doing when you first start out trading
and risking a small amount. In this
trade example right here, this is a real
trade I've taken on a small account. I'm
risking about $100 per trade here. And
you can risk a lot less than that. I'm
trading five contracts here actually
based on this number five. So, you could
do one of that. You could be risking $20
on this trade. So, you can start really
small. And what you want to be doing
when you first start out is you want to
be just going for quick, easy wins. You
want to keep your management of your
trades as simple as possible. Now, first
off, I want to get in a little bit more
of how my strategy works and how I
actually find these trades. Now, you can
see initially I am betting here that the
market is going to go down. And so, you
can make money betting the market's
going to go up or you can bet money that
the market's going to go down. It's
really, really simple. You know, you
don't have to do anything complicated.
It's called shorting. And it sounds a
little complicated, but really at the
end of the day, you just be clicking a
sell button instead of a buy button, and
you're making money as the market goes
down, which is actually in your favor in
that case. Now, the first step to every
trade I take is finding those big
picture resistance or support zones. And
so for this particular trade, if I go
back in the chart and look is that the
market was coming up to this area and
just looking at the big swings, we had
touched up here twice already. And so I
was I drew this box. Now, I'm not going
to go over these. I'll link a video that
dives way more in depth than how to how
to draw support and resistance levels
and the five key things I look for. But
essentially, I said, "Okay, I like this
area in the market." you know,
resistance and support zones can be
pretty subjective. You know, you could
be up here, you could be down here. But
the idea is if it comes up anywhere in
this area, I want to look for the market
to potentially reverse, right? And
capture a move down off of that area.
And so this is I draw these levels off
of a 15minute chart and then I enter in
my trades on a one or five minute chart.
What this does is drawn on a bigger
picture time frame is it just allows you
to see the bigger picture. And I always
found that the higher levels that the
levels from there are just higher
probability because they're on a bigger
time frame versus the smaller levels.
There can be a lot more whipssaw back
and forth. And so the market right here
that we're looking at is coming up into
this support level here. It doesn't pop
up on this chart here because I think
it's slightly out of view just because
it's kind of that big picture. But
that's my idea here is first off, we're
coming up into that level. And then the
second step is well, there is this big
move up here and I've drawn an uptrend
line and all I'm looking for is because
when you're counter trend trading, well,
you kind of need to make sure that you
know the trend that you're going against
is over, right? And so there's a big
move right here and I'm thinking, okay,
I like this to go back. Thinking about
that rubber band effect we talked about,
right? It's likely to come up and if it
gives that back up, it's going to snap
back. And often times it'll snap back to
kind of where it started. And so what
I'm looking for here is I'm looking for
it to do that. And I actually have a buy
limit down here that it almost just hit
and then is reversed off of a little
bit. And so that's all I'm looking for
is just that quick move. And what you
want to do when you first start out, I
highly suggest this is go for a fixed
profit target. Now, I do it a little
more complicated here because I am more
advanced trading on a smaller account.
But if we zoom back to the start of this
trade is all you need to do is when you
enter in a trade is enter in here and
then I like to put my stop loss where
I'm going to get out if the trade goes
against me is in a key area. you know,
essentially above the swing here because
I think that, hey, I think this is a
rubber band effect, it's likely to snap
back, it'll do that quickly if it does.
And if it's just in a strong trend where
it's just going to bounce and keep going
higher, cut your losses, right? Remember
about that riskreward. We want to just
risk that $100, lose the $100 if we're
wrong, or if we're right, you know, we
collect $200 or $300 because the worst
thing that you can do as a beginning
trader, and I see people do this, is
they'll take their stop loss that sets
at, you know, at $100 risk, and they'll
say, "Oh, let me move it up here a
little bit more or a little bit more.
Give the trade a little bit more wiggle
room." And most of the time, the best
trades happen and work out quickly in
your favor. and the ones that don't,
they're just not going to work out no
matter how much room you give them. And
so, it's better to just cut your losses
and move on. And so, once I jump in
here, that's what I'm looking for is the
market to kind of give that move back
up. That's a great target. And so, when
you enter into a trade, you want to make
sure there's that room profit. You want
to visually see, okay, this rubber band
can give me about two times, two and a
half times my risk in profit if it goes
down to that area. because if it if it
doesn't have that, it's not worth the
risk. There's no good opportunity there.
That's your edge in the market is making
sure that there's opportunity for you to
put that limit order in an area that
makes sense. And so you can see just
kind of looking at the movement of the
market, it's kind of in an uptrend right
here. And so I was keeping track of,
well, there's this uptrend here. Keep in
mind, we could come down here and the
bigger overall trend takes control and
we push up from there. And so that's a
little more advanced market reading
there, but the idea is, you know, we
have this small move that I'm looking
for the market to give up and then that
big picture level, you know, hopefully
comes and stacks onto this and pushes it
down even more. And so the last thing to
jump in on these trades is I like to see
a candlestick pattern. I like to see
some kind of head and shoulders pattern.
you know, a a pattern where there's a
big bearish bar here, you know, a
threeline strike pattern essentially. Or
you can see here as well, this
candlestick, the market essentially, if
you look at what these do, and if you
kind of read into what they're saying,
the market kind of came up here in this
uptrend and then it it sold off and then
it made them one more attempt to go
higher. That's what this candle is
showing. It it attempts to go higher and
then it comes back down. And so what
that shows me is there is essentially a
micro double top here. And in that trend
in terms of giving back this rubber band
effect, that's a really good signal to
jump in short here and bet the market's
gonna go down. And so from there, you
know, just set your limit order and just
leave it. Now, I do suggest uh when it
gets close like this is you can move
your stop-loss at least to break even,
but generally it's better to just try
and just focus on your entries. What you
want to do when you're first starting
out trading is master the entries of
getting it in. Managing your trades will
get you a little bit more money. You
know, let's say increase your profits by
10%. But your entries are going to be
90% of what makes or breaks your
trading. And so learning to just focus
on those and not think about the
management as much because that just
adds again more variables. And the more
simpler you can make trading, the
better. And so just to walk you through
kind of what I did here is all I did
was, you know, it it almost hit my
profit target there and I thought, hey,
you know, I see it in this downtrend
here and I'll just move my stop down and
see if I can get a little bit more in
the trade. And we'll talk about some
more complex management steps in the
next phase here so you can know kind of
what to do when you get a little more
comfortable reading the charts. And so
my trade pretty much got knocked out
here and I think about, you know, 180 or
something. So, you know, about two times
my risk, which was still pretty much
what my target was at. And so that's
again a great trade. And you just move
on to the next one. And so let's jump in
right into phase two. And our second
trade where I'm actually risking I think
$200 to $300 of risk here. And then this
is what you want to do once you become a
little more comfortable with trading.
And you can see that this is a very very
similar setup in terms of just the
market moves up, it comes into a
resistance level that I'm looking for,
and I'm just looking for that rubber
band effect to move the market back
down. And I found that this is just
really, really repetitive and
consistent. That's how you make money
trading is not learning 10 different
strategies or 10 different patterns to
make money off of. It's taking one
strategy, keeping it simple, and scaling
up. You can trade a $100 with this
pattern and easily scale to $1,000. It's
just a number at the end of the day. You
know, it's going to get a little more
stressful at $1,000, but that's why you
slowly build up to it so you can get
used to that amount of money. When I
first started out trading, you know,
risking $50 felt crazy and super
intense. And now, you know, at a blink
of an eye, I feel like I can put $500
worth of risk on a trade. you just get
used to it. And so to walk you through
this trade entry and then how the
management style can change over time is
first off is again always looking for
that larger resistance level just off of
those swings off of a larger time frame.
I use a 15-minute I have some students
who use like an hour time frame to do
that. And then it's just seeing okay we
have a good trend here but it's started
to kind of get overextended right here.
Here you can see with these three, you
know, five 10 candlesticks that kind of
started to skyrocket here and then it
started to slow down. And so for me, I
see that as okay, well, I see kind of an
uptrend here. You know, it's kind of
getting methodical, but it kind of got
overextended and it's near that area
where I'm already expecting it to
reverse. And so having that as a
combination, it stacks on top of each
other and increases the likelihood for
it to happen. And then from there, it's
just looking for that kind of a
candlestick pattern to show it's
starting to reverse. And for me, that
was well, we had a really big sell-off
right here. These four red candlesticks
shows a lot of selling. And if you look
at, we hadn't really had that much kind
of selling pressure. Four candles in a
row for quite a while. And once it's
kind of moved up here, especially after
this, I think that's a good combination
with it coming here and making two lower
highs. And that's the whole thing is
just reading the basics of, okay, well,
a uptrend is made out of higher highs
and higher lows. And it when it's going
to shift, well, it's going to start
making lower lows and lower highs. And
so here it makes a higher low and then a
lower low. And then here it's making two
lower highs from this peak that it made.
And so from there I elect to jump in
short on this bearish candlestick right
here cuz the market if you kind of read
into these two candlesticks it it shoots
up and then it shoots lower kind of
confirming that lower high. And so for
me that's a good enough confirmation
with you know the support level the
uptrend broken and then those lower
highs coming into play. And then of
course looking at the bigger picture of
this kind of rubber band move up likely
to push lower. And then from there I
just jump in. And to kind of show you
once it kind of moves lower now I've
started to move into more of a fluid
management style. The stop here is above
this high right here because I think
that hey this is a swing low. I'm
assuming that we're going to start
moving slower off of that. And if it
breaks this instead, you know, and comes
up here and and and makes a higher high,
well, you know, this uptrend is going to
keep going and I just want to cut my
losses, right? And so from there, it
starts to go in my favor and I'm looking
at more, okay, I'm not looking for two
times fixed profit target anymore. I'm
looking for three fluidly. And what I
mean by that is I have a profit target
all the way down here at about three
times my risk. And as it starts to move
in my favor, I'm going to move my stop
loss further down. And if it really gets
going, I'm going to move this further
down as well. And I'm just going to
slowly move my stop-loss down and my
profit target down. But I'm also going
to manage with how I see the market
moving. And in this case, the market
starts making a really tight downtrend
right here. And often I've observed when
I see the market coming up here in a
clean methodical way and then making a
really tight downtrend, I want to
capture this move here, but as soon as
it starts to, you know, become a broader
downtrend, I don't want to hold through
those pullbacks and swings that the
market could have because at this point,
well, it could actually bottom and start
an uptrend right here. And so what I
decided to do was essentially manage
with this downtrend line. So that's
something new that I started doing as I
became more comfortable with
understanding the market and being in a
trade is I would be okay to as soon as
there was a candlestick close or two
outside of this trend line or with idea
of saying hey if it breaks above this
candlestick it's probably breaking above
and out of this trend line. I'm going to
close out and get out of the trade. And
so there I I closed out for a good
profit, captured this, you know, move
down. And I think from there, you know,
looking at this, it it looks like we
could have a retracement up. Now, it
could come up here and keep going lower.
But again, I've captured the the easy
money and the part that is just good
enough for me at that point. You know, I
don't want to deal with the choppiness
of the market and the fact that it could
just give all those profits back up. I,
you know, am reading the movement of the
market. Now, of course, sometimes it can
just have a little pullback and puke
lower, and that's a part of managing
your trades. So, now let's go into
another trade where I'm actually risking
$600 per trade. And let me walk you
through the intricacies of how to scale
in and scale out of a trade. This is
definitely a lot more complicated. And
so I highly suggest don't do this when
you're first starting out, but it shows
you the power of how to do it. This is
actually a long example of a trade we're
in that big picture support zone. We've
actually kind of broken out of it.
That's okay. I like to call those a
failed breakout. It's it's just
attempting to fail and break out the
other side. But, you know, I have this
downtrend line in place. And then you
can see there's kind of some big moves
up here that show strength to me. And
then we have one more push lower. I see
this as a final attempt to go lower. And
then right here, boom, we have a double
bottom. This is a nice bullish bar. I
think at this point, it's essentially
confirming a double bottom here. And I
think it's worth jumping in a trade long
here, putting my stop loss below here,
and getting long. And so, the first
thing though with that is I didn't feel
super confident right away just because
it it felt like there was a lot of
downwards pressure right here. And so I,
you know, elected to, well, give it a
couple candlesticks here. See, okay, if
it's going to make one more push lower
here, boom, I definitely want to get in.
If that candlestick reverses, I think
that's showing a lot of strength. So, I
jump in there. But I'm actually not full
size here. I'm 2/3 size. Full size here
for $600 on this particular trade is
three contracts. And so what made me
more confident was waiting for this
candlestick to close out really bullish
that I thought was a strong signal, a
strong bullish bar. It had, you know,
made this kind of little couple dogeis
here and then it had made this strong
candlestick. So I put in an order, a
stop market order above that,
essentially getting in long at the break
of this candlestick and then I matched
it down with my stops down here. So
essentially that made my total risk to
be $600. that's kind of my full size at
the time. And so one thing what you can
do is you don't have to necessarily
scale in. You can also just trade
smaller size. You know, let's say uh
full risk is, you know, $600 and that's,
you know, three out of three, but you
can also just trade one/ird size and
that's it. You know, you could just risk
$200 on a trade because, you know,
you're not as confident in it. The
level's not as strong. There's not as
much of a, you know, flush like this,
right? And so that's what you can do is
when you're not as confident in spots or
if you're just not feeling on top of
your game, you can trade smaller size as
well because of that. And so that is two
ways to kind of change how you enter
into trades because that's going to
allow you to control and manage your
risk. And really good trading is when
you control and manage your risk. when
if you're not confident but you still
think it's worth putting a trade on, you
do smaller size. And when you are
confident, that's when you put on larger
size because when it comes to trading,
no two trades are the same. You know,
all these patterns are very similar, but
they're not the same at the end of the
day. You know, the market's always
different. And so over time and by the
time you get to here, you're going to
build that intuition into knowing kind
of when you want to put full size on and
when you want to put smaller size on.
And so once this kind of broke out to be
two times my risk here, I move to break
even because, you know, there's no
reason to let it come all the way back
here and turn into a loss, right? And so
what I'm I'm looking for at this point
is I'm just kind of giving it a mental
stop at this point. If the market pulls
back all the way here and just flushes
and knocks me out, it'll do that and
knock me out at break even. That's
always what goes on in my mind usually
when I'm doing this. But it's so
unlikely that it happens. Usually, most
likely what will happen is it pulls
back, you know, and and makes a couple
candlesticks before, you know, deciding
which way to go and and then then you
can move your stop loss above that. And
so that's kind of what I did here just
to kind of skip forward to kind of show
you that is it, you know, it doesn't
look good. It's like, okay, well, maybe
it's just going to give this back up.
But you can see it starts to find a
bottom here. And I then move my stop
loss up and we start to get some
volatility here. There's a little bit of
news that came out. And so that's why I
don't like to do a profit target in some
points because well it allows you to
have these massive moves where you know
I think $1,800 was three times my risk
and this kind of move well I'm thinking
okay well we've come back all the way up
to here on the left side here. You can
see that we've kind of given back this
rubber band move but it allows you to
have the potential to get massive moves.
And if you look at other trades on my
channel, I get some massive moves
sometimes. And so to just walk you
through quickly is I actually then
started to scale out of this trade. And
so what I did was the market had this
big candlestick up. It had a pullback.
And my observation with these is, hey,
if it if it's going to hold this, it's
going to hold it. And so I would rather
scale out of two/ird my trade there and,
you know, capture those quick profits.
But then also, you know, I have this
uptrend here I'm watching. And so that's
why I left one of these contracts on.
Hey, you know, maybe it has a little bit
of a snap here, knocks me out, and then
it takes off and and holds this uptrend.
And so that's what I'm kind of looking
for here. And it looks pretty good right
here, especially since it barely locked
out my my two other contracts, which
it's a part of trading. It's going to be
frustrating. You're going to have trades
where you just barely get knocked out
and then it goes thousands of dollars of
profit in your way. And it just is what
it is. You don't want to focus on those
small times where okay well maybe I
should adjust my strategy to fit that
little bit. You want to be again focus
on the big picture of okay well what
generally works and makes me the most
money. You can't control the infinite
possibilities that the market has and
that it's going to throw at you. And so
now at this point it's not looking that
great since it's pretty much just made
this double top right here. And so at
that point, I'm going to move my stop
loss essentially with the idea that,
hey, it's breaking this uptrend. And,
you know, I I I'm going to get out my
my, you know, I still want to capture
the profits that this move looks like
it's going to do. And so, you know, it
has that double bottom here, and I just
moved my stop loss up to there, and it
knocks me out. Okay, coming into today,
I've taken a few days off from trading.
And so, it helps me to get back into the
swing of things by visualizing what I
want to do, reminding myself how my
strategy works and what I'm looking for.
You know, what is that repeatable thing
that I'm looking for every day versus
just kind of showing up and being like,
"Okay, I'm just going to trade." Um, and
so for me, um, one of those big things
is
going into, um,
some of my recordings of just past
trades that have done well that are
basically just are wins that hit my
criteria and seeing that, you know, it's
like, hey, I want to just see the market
come up to a spot
um, and
hit kind of make a double top, hit my
timing window, and then take a trade
based off of that. And so for me, that
helps me, you know, kind of trigger.
Okay, I'm not looking to just do random
things or react to the market. I want to
wait for a specific thing, you know, a
nice spike 8:00 or 30 minutes after the
market open to show up and then, you
know, take a a reversal. And that's kind
of my bread and butter. And essentially,
that's what my repeatable setup is. And
so going into today, looking for
something like that. If we look at the
ES futures, just to bring up my drawing
tool here, um on a 15-minute chart, you
know, we had a crazy sell-off um Friday.
And this was just Trump announced some
kind of tariff news on China. I think he
tweeted it or something, but the market
just went crazy over it. like looking at
a daily chart
um you know was a it was a huge spike
down um and so
you know we came to actually these
previous highs which I think is a great
spot for a bottom um and if if he
doesn't really follow through you know
the thought is is it just going to be
you know a smaller version of April
where we just rip lower and then once
people were like oh he's kind of backed
off on that um we might just shoot back
up because the market overall is
insanely strong right now and so I think
it's totally possible that today looking
at this we probably want to retest this
to some extent and we have done that um
you know we started to recover pull back
this really kind of tested this the gap
we had there's still technically it
closed here and opened here so there's a
pretty big gap there but we have come
down to to really fill this gap this is
the major gap here. Haven't quite filled
it. So, I could see us selling off a bit
more to do that. Same thing with the
NASDAQ. Pretty much exactly the same
setup. Um is we've had this downtrend or
trailing off. Um started to fill this
gap, at least tested the middle of it.
And so, going into a smaller chart, what
that looks like for a trade today. Well,
you know, 8:00 is here. Sometimes you
can get a reversal 15 minutes after the
open, but today I think if we can get a
good bottom, I think it's totally
reasonable actually going back to a
15-minute chart here is if we
target these overnight highs. Um, you
know, the market kind of just giving
back this move up, finding some
strength.
Uh, but just got to pick the right time
to buy at the bottom for that. And so,
uh, market hasn't opened yet. got 7:30
my time is when it opens and then other
couple windows I like 7:45 and 8. These
are my two spots where I want to see it
come down in reverse if it's you know
either way at those timings. Um that's
kind of lines up with what is repeatable
for me versus I find you know going into
the market and
just trying to enter in randomly just
does not work very well. um or or
reacting and just reading and thinking I
can read the market in real time um if
it doesn't fit one of those kind of
things. So um another thing would
potentially be well if it comes down
um bounces and then sits here for a
minute and looks like it's going to go
long maybe like a fake lower and then
goes long that could be another
potential trade of a fake out lower um
to again try to fill my bias to the long
side.
So, what I would like for a long here
now that it's broken the lows,
um, I would want a head and shoulders to
go long here because otherwise it it's
way more likely that we just, especially
for the NASDAQ here, is come up here,
test this, and just continue lower
because we're not really bouncing off of
a a support level. Now, we we could just
be doing a failed breakout of the
overnight lows here, but big picture, we
could just be in a downtrend
um that's going to continue lower, you
know, and so
I don't want to jump in long here
saying, "Hey, that's a nice failed break
lower um when this downtrend is so
strong.
I like this to the upside.
I really want to see. I'm nervous that
I'm just going to it's just going to
pump me in and then rip lower, but I
think I'm just going to get in long
um through that nervousness because
it it's made a nice head and shoulders
there. I'm going to just put my stop
down here.
adjust this slightly.
Um, and then target the highs.
It's a nice setup. Maybe I should have
my stop down here. It's just hard when
it's such a a rip. NASDAQ has kind of
done the same head and shoulders. I
think it looks really solid.
In terms of a setup, we had a nice flush
lower, nice little fail breakout lower.
In terms of target, I mean, initial is
going to be here.
Um, the previous open
or or the open of today, which is
basically here.
Uh, if we rip up and hit 2x pretty fast,
I might jump out.
Um, but I mean ideally we try and go for
the highs, but also one thing to keep in
mind
is pulling up a channel here
is we could totally be in this kind of
channel right here.
It's not super defined.
You know, it's kind of off of these
three, but that's pretty solid in terms
of resistance. So, so there's this
downtrend line here from that channel.
If it does like a two candlestick
pullback here, just like this, and then
continues higher, I want to I want to
hold through that. I don't want to get
ripped out by that.
It's scary at this size. And I'm still
getting used to that
and it' be really frustrating if it
does.
But pulling back, you know, looking at
the NASDAQ here, trying to be unbiased
that I'm in a trade. Pulling back to
here and going higher is totally
reasonable.
Just kind of waiting to see what happens
at this point. Okay, nice rip higher
here.
Again, looking at this, um, I'm just
going to take this out to clean up my
chart a bit, being aware that there's
this downtrend here. We could still
totally just reverse after that pop up
and it could be like a final fake li
higher.
Same thing on the NASDAQ.
I think if we break break my stop here,
it's basically breaking this uptrend.
Anyway,
I'm happy with how I'm managing it. I
just emotionally I really would love a a
win that's higher than
$1,700 if I get stopped out. I'll be a
little bummed about that. But again, at
the end of the day, I
the entry was really good, which is what
I've been struggling with. Management
you know, that just plays out how it
plays out. It's just emotions talking
really
big picture. Again, this is such a good
for, you know, this whole swing. It's a
nice fake lower
and reversal higher. This is what I've
been looking for for weeks really with a
lot of these openings is reverse or fake
the way I don't want and then take a
trade the direction that my bias is or I
think the big picture is.
I'm just going to move this down to 3x
at this point.
I I think that's emotional. I want to
see what how this plays out.
I definitely if this starts popping up
here, I'm going to move trailing stop
like really tight here now
like up to 2x.
NASDAQ is popping as well.
For me, mentally, I feel like getting 5K
on the trade is kind of a mental number
I really want right now.
Um, it's not good, but that's just the
reality.
But I also don't want to just let that
control what I'm doing. I want to run a
trailing stop here if this is just going
to continue to pop.
I don't think that's over greed. I think
that's,
you know, I I'm just going to put a
trailing stop here right at the bottom
of this candle because I think either
it's going to keep going up or it's
going to knock me out. And if it knocks
me out here at 4700,
I'm totally happy with that.
Come on, hold and keep going.
That's okay. I'm totally happy with
that. So in the next few minutes I'm
going to give you a complete crash
course on how futures work. Now the
first thing is futures are not like your
normal stocks and buying shares. You can
buy a share of let's say Microsoft and
it will go up or down over time and
you'll make or lose money but you can
hold that share for as long as the
company exists. But with futures, you
buy something called a contract. And
this contract will expire once every
either month or even 3 months depending
on what kind of asset you're trading.
And this contract's value is tied to the
physical asset. So let's say for
something like gold futures, as gold
goes up or down, your futures contract
on gold will also go up or down in
value, but usually it'll be a lot more
than the price movement of gold. So what
this allows you to do is get a lot of
leverage on that specific asset. So for
example with gold is you are essentially
buying a contract saying that I will buy
let's say 100 ounces of gold at this
current price in the future and once
that contract is used or expires you
have that ability to do that but in
practicality sense nobody really ever
does that at least for you know retail
traders like you and me. What people do
is they just buy and sell the contracts
and get the dollar value increase or
decrease of the contract and essentially
trade using that. It essentially allows
you to day trade with a very high
leverage and able to capture up and down
moves just like trading shares. Now, to
get control of these assets, you have to
put up collateral. It's called margin.
And essentially what you're doing is you
have let's say $500 taken out of your
account to get control over one gold
futures contract. Now this margin can
depend on either what asset you're
trading, how volatile the market is, or
if it's during normal stock market
hours, which is called intraday margin,
or overnight margin, which is outside of
normal stock market hours. Intraday
margin is usually extremely low because
the volatility and risk is a lot less
but overnight margin is a lot more where
you lose a lot more of that leverage
potential and it can take up to 10 times
the intraday margin to get control over
that asset. Now you also have something
called the micro futures and all they
are is they are a micro tiny asset of
the larger normal futures contract. So,
if a gold futures contract takes you
$500 worth of margin, the micro gold
futures contract takes $50 worth of
margin. So, you can essentially trade a
very small account. And what this allows
you to do is start with a small account
and grow it at a normal pace. You don't
have to be risking a huge amount of
money when you first start out trading.
You can trade micro futures and risk 20
or $30 in one trade. Now, there
definitely are risks when it comes to
trading futures. The margin isn't your
max loss on a futures contract.
Technically, you can lose more than that
if the market moves very quickly against
you, especially if you hold it through
the close, but really in reality, I
haven't really seen that ever happen.
The way to avoid that is a stop-loss
always in place when you're in a trade.
And most of the time, your futures
brokerage will close you out before your
account goes negative and you start to
lose a crazy amount of money. Now, the
most confusing thing with futures is the
price movement and how it's calculated.
Every futures contract is slightly
different. The minimum price movement is
called a tick. So if you think about
with shares, every stock like our share
of Microsoft, it can move up or down one
penny at the smallest amount of movement
most of the time because it's based on
the dollar. Now a lot of futures are not
based on a dollar. With gold, it
technically is, but something like the
S&P 500 futures, if it goes up a
numerical value of one, that doesn't
mean the index increases by $1 value.
But instead, one numerical jump is
called one point. And then the smallest
movement possible, at least for the S&P
500 futures, is 0.25. And this is called
a tick. A tick is the smallest price
movement in the futures market that
you're looking at. For oil, a tick is
0.01. And each tick is valued
differently. So for oil, if you're
trading the normal tick size, the not
the micro futures of oil, each tick or
0.01 01 worth of movement is worth $10.
For the S&P 500 futures, each tick is
0.25 worth of movement and it's worth
$1,250. And then the micro versions of
those are just a tenth of the size. And
so you can see where the value and the
movement of each chart is way different.
Now, the cool thing about futures in the
US, 60% of your profits count as
long-term capital gains and 40% count as
short-term. And so, that's a huge tax
reduction for long-term use of futures
compared to trading other assets. If I
double $50 just 10 times, it's over
$50,000. But if I lose just once, the
challenge is over. But I'm not trading
every day. I'm only trading a clean
reversal setup that fits my strategy.
This isn't some gambling flipping game
where I'm just trying to see how much
money I can make in a crazy amount
exponentially. It's about showing you
what's possible if you follow a
disciplined, consistent strategy. And
above all, have patience. So, let's see
how far I can actually get and put my
money where my mouth is starting with
just $50. So, day one here, I'm going to
jump in on a trade right here. based off
of a five-minute chart. This is in gold.
It's made a clean double bottom. We're
at a good support and it's broken this
downtrend. And so, I'm going to let it
play out based on that. I'm going to put
my stop below this big green
candlestick. The size is a little bit
larger than 50. It's kind of hard when
it's such a small account, but we're
going to see if this can reverse here
and we can get a nice win initially.
And I think it's about to pretty much
close me out here at 1 and 1/2x. But you
know what? First trade off $84, $120 up.
If it does close me out right here, it's
still capturing like a 100 bucks. So,
I'm pretty happy with that.
So, I'm in the second trade here and
it's going pretty well so far. The first
off, the reason why I got in, we're
looking at the NASDAQ. This is on a
larger picture time frame chart,
15minute chart. Um, we're here right
now, but before we did a big bounce
here, move up, you know, couple, this is
like kind of two days over the weekend,
came back down here, and now it's it's
in a good spot to bounce. And so that's
why then I come into
a smaller time frame chart here. And,
you know, this is a one minute chart.
Now, you can see this trend down, pushed
up, made some nice strong move, kind of
it started to find some strength, and
then when it broke out, bought in. And
now I'm looking for it to pretty much
just go back up to this hive right here.
Well, this challenge is going to be
really short. The trade is pretty much
at full loss here, but you know, I guess
that's how it goes sometimes.
Oh my god. I kid you not. I literally
thought it was done.
Look at this thing.
It reversed like just before my stop
loss here and now we're ripping back up
higher. I'm pretty sure it's just going
to get me out at full win here for a
second as this move is that's a really
nice pullback. Sick trade. I'm glad it
didn't wipe me out on these last
seconds. Sometimes it's just so insane
just watching that just almost tick
there and then not like I want to move
my stop loss up right here and then
having a pullback. It's just psychotic.
I think I'm going to move my stop loss
up right here.
So, I'm nervous about this. But again,
the reasons to get in are good. This
could just be like a final push higher
that fails. This candlestick right here
is pretty strong. It's just a an attempt
in a new high and then it's going to
fail. I would like to see how this does
this kind of bottom here and then
continue higher. But I think if the
NASDAQ gives up, this is going to push
lower. So I think I'm going to put in an
order below this. It's a good setup. New
high, lower high. Big picture is good.
And I'm going to put my stop above the
highs and I'm going to manage
accordingly. Nice failure there. Again,
like the big thing is this could just
come down and bottom and continue
higher. So, this point just kind of let
it do its thing. See how it plays out.
Again, like this looking even on a fivem
minute, that's a nice fivem minute
candle. Um, but we'll see what it does.
One egg. That tray is done.
Double two. Now we're on to four.
I'm going to go long here. If it breaks
above this previous candlestick, I think
just to go 1x here, it's a nice signal
to hit just this swing high. We don't
even have to go high that high up. And
that, you know, past that swing. I think
that's totally reasonable of a move.
Just going to see how this plays out.
Okay, we are in. Put my target again.
I'm kind of nervous about this one. It
just doesn't feel great. The setup's
there. Big picture. We're at a nice
level. We've had a massive move down. My
inclination this morning that the market
was going to do a pullback and push
higher. The ES is actually looking
stronger. I would say it's pretty choppy
at this point. I'm taking that trade at
8:30, which is kind of like not a great
hour. But if this candlestick finishes
forming like this on a fivem minute,
this looks clean.
Wait, I'm only in four contracts over
here. No, that's so upsetting. Come on,
just fill that. I need more contracts.
Oh no. Okay, now our risk is better.
Okay, as that is a little funky. Still
legitimately doing this. We're going to
get out when it hits 400 in profit. I
didn't even realize I was in less
contracts. I I was looking at it and I
was like, I'm not up enough money for
where it is based on the chart. So now
it's fine. Now we just need it to go up.
Normally, if I was just going to get out
at basically 1x, I would just get out
right here cuz it's clearly showing some
resistance and breaking through that
previous swing where that weird news
blip was right here. Had a random candle
that just shot lower. Um was just not
worth it essentially, but you know, I'm
going to let it play out. I mean, it
looks solid. It's going to hit me. So, I
think it's going to be basically at 400,
too. 380, 407,
415. Sick. Done with that. On to risking
800 a trade now, which is pretty close
to my main size.
Okay, so opening up the charts this
morning. The ES futures are look like
they're trying to put in maybe a double
top off all-time highs. Um, not really
in a spot where I like. NASDAQ has
already pushed all-time highs. It's kind
of holding this up trend still. Um, so
kind of mixed signals there. So, not
something super great on that front. Uh,
in terms of gold this morning, big
selloff into not really a great level.
Um, overall I think it looks like it's
in more of a downtrend, like it wants
to, you know, continue down and and
somehow find a bounce down here
eventually. Um,
with the market looking bullish, I mean,
we could, you know, in five minutes,
it's a really nice sell-off. Really
overextended. I just I'd be worried it
comes up here off of this kind of like
bottom and just sells off. Not a ton of
opportunities this morning, but you
know, you never know. I I I never try
and just say, "Oh, I know what the
market's going to do and not watch it,
right?" You never know what it's going
to do. It's totally something good could
set up.
I am going to enter in $800 here,
thinking that we're going to keep this
momentum higher. I just entered in more
contracts than I'd like for some reason.
So, we're a slightly larger size than
800. We are risking more like a
thousand.
Great. Well, mistakes happen. It's still
a good spot. I want to see us push up
from here. Now, granted, I could be a
little early. Like, really, I should be
waiting for this 5 minute to close cuz
it could just come up here and and show
a little failure. And, you know, maybe I
I then just FOMOed into this. I'm going
to try and close five contracts out
here. See, that's um it's not the right
amount. I shouldn't be in that many. I
would like to be in the correct amount.
Just kind of a an oops, I would say.
Okay, now we just um sit on our hands
and knees and wait for this to hopefully
print money.
Okay, let's see. While I painfully watch
this trade, it's going to bounce, I
swear. Okay, gold all of a sudden is
moving crazily. I don't know what that's
from. That's a really nice sign for this
trade. Then it'll just shoot up from
here now. That would be sick. I would
take that. Just reverse $800 on me. Five
minute. I mean, five minute looks good.
That's a nice double bottom. 15minut.
Honestly, it looks like it's good
potential to keep going higher. We don't
need it to go that much higher. It
doesn't need to go that high for this.
Oh, if it just rips up and then rips
lower like that, that's going to be an
emotional roller coaster that I would
have preferred to not be a part of.
Come on, baby. Break out. That's all I
need you to do. Just break out. If you
break out, I'll give you a cookie. I
have a cookie right here. Look, there's
a cookie. I'll give you a cookie. Come
on. You got it. There you go. There you
go. Yep. That's what we want. Also, if
you're wondering what trading platform
I'm using, it's called Ninja Trader.
I've used it for over 5 years. It's
amazing. I'll leave a link in the
description below this video if you want
to check it out. That candle does not
look good. That is not a good looking
like action. Does not look good. 15
minutes looks about the same. I'm going
to go walk outside.
Come on. No. Oh, it was so close. No,
don't tease me. It's so close. Come on.
You got it. You got it. You got it. I
still have that cookie for you. Come on.
5 minute looks great. Keep it going, my
guy.
Come on. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. There you go. Yes. Oh, it's
closing. Woo. Close. Damn. That was
crazy seeing the contract slowly close
in like real time with that limit order.
on to 1600.
Okay, so I'm a bit behind this morning,
but looking at let's see, starting with
oil cuz this looks the best. It's kind
of bouncing. Had a massive sell off
yesterday. Big sell off this morning.
Continued kind of at this initial level.
There's a bigger level down here, but
kind of zooming in. It's definitely at a
spot where we could get a bounce. Gold
looks like it could be bouncing here
too. It just had a spike lower here and
it's kind of coming into this, you know,
overnight level. And then the market is
big selloff yesterday. So right now both
of these are kind of in the middle of
their range. you know, looking at a one
minute of NASDAQ and ES. They had, you
know, a nice little spike in the open,
but that again, that's not really what
I'm looking for. And maybe see if if the
NASDAQ and the ES make some kind of
drastic move in some direction, like
maybe come down here, set something up
to look like to go long. Maybe
I'm going to jump in here. I really hope
I didn't miss it by not having my order
in again. I would probably
cry and go back to bed. Oh my god.
Please fill me. Please pull back just
just a smidge and fill me. Oh, that's
brutal. Should I just chase it there?
I'm just trying to do too many things at
once. And now if it pops up there, I'm
like, do I even want to be in it? Oh, I
should I could have literally just put
my order here. It would have been
filled. It literally one ticked me. What
is NASDAQ look like? I mean, that's a
nice signal overall, you know? I mean,
maybe I'm trying to just like be too too
tight with my entries right now. I don't
know. I'm going to see put in a
different order. See if I can get filled
on it. I really don't want to chase. I
think it looks good, but I don't want to
I don't want to chase up there. Come on,
my guy. Fill me. Even gold looks like it
wants to bottom here. Just be patient.
It's going to come to you. It's really
not that far. It's probably going to
come pull back and pull back a lot. Come
on. Try not to be tortured by this right
now. If this breaks up without me, I'm
definitely calling it a day. Just
looking at these on like a five minute
and the NASDAQ. They look good. Okay,
we're filled. Okay, now just don't don't
just puke lower on me now. That would
just be rude. Yeah, there you go. Yeah,
just get me. Oh, the torture of trading
sometimes is just a little agonizing.
So, I'm actually in based on the fill,
I'm actually basically in 1,900 over
here. Man, if this just rips up and
fills me for two grand right here, that
would be sick.
No, I don't want to move out to break
even like that yet.
Just going to let it play out.
I don't want to overmanage because I'm
frustrated and all that. Just let it
play out. The Pops in a good spot. Big
picture. It looks great. I think I
needed miracle at this point to save
this trade,
which sucks.
It's happened before. Still in. Wish I
went long gold. It's why we keep it
below the low before it makes an actual
breakout.
I'm kind of surprised cuz this on a
fivem minute looks pretty solid.
We haven't broken the five minute signal
yet. Be breaking this low. So, Yeah,
that's just kind of surprising.
Feels way more like gambling and intense
with
this challenge of like not wanting to
lose feels way more intense.
And the fact that it's the last trade it
pulled back on me in reverse.
This trade,
I'm not going to say anything. I don't
want to jinx it.
Oh my god. Yes, dude. Oh my god. That
was the most painful thing ever. Oh my
god. I really thought I was screwed on
that one. Oh my god.
Oh man, that was ridiculous. Oh my gosh.
That was intense.
So, I've actually decided to stop this
challenge right here. That last trade
was pretty emotional. You saw how up and
down it was. The whole idea with trading
is to make money. Eventually, I'd lose
if I'm betting my account every time.
Just to show you my results here, this
took me pretty much 20 days, but I'm up
a total of over $3,05.
It's really important to know when to
actually stop and reset because
otherwise you're going to go on a
massive win streak and blow it. If
you've been trading for a while, you've
probably felt stuck. Like no matter what
you do, you keep running in circles. You
put the work in, you watch the videos,
you tweak your strategy, but somehow
you're still not making consistent
money. That's because almost every
trader falls into two dangerous cycles.
And if you don't break out of them,
they're going to continue draining your
time, your money, and your confidence.
And the first one is the learning loop,
where you are stuck in research mode,
constantly tweaking, and never being
consistent with one specific strategy.
And the second one I call the
self-sabotage loop, where you're now
consistently executing a strategy, but
you're making emotional mistakes that
continuously wipe out your progress.
These loops can keep you spinning for
years, blowing up accounts, hesitating
on good trades, and worst of all,
wasting the one thing you can't get
back, your time. But once you understand
these loops and how they work, you can
break free from them. And I know this
works because I've had students stuck in
these exact same loops. And once they
realize that, made a few key tweaks,
they've been able to turn their trading
around. Now, let's get into the meat of
this and go through how these two loops
work and how you can break free from
them. And first, we're going to start
off with the most common loop that stops
95% of traders from even starting to
become successful at trading. And I call
it the learning loop where you are just
learning and tweaking your strategy so
much that you never give yourself time
to actually start practicing and
becoming good at the strategy. The whole
idea of how this loop works is, you
know, however you're learning content
probably through YouTube since you're
here is you, you know, you find a new
strategy and, you know, you start to
learn new patterns, you learn my
strategy and you start kind of
practicing it. You test it out and it's
not really working for you. You know,
you maybe have some success initially,
you know, in the first week or two, but
over time you're not getting those
consistent results over the long term,
right? And then from that point, well,
you know, logically when you are
learning anything in the world, it makes
sense to go learn more, right? Because
adding more information and learning
more information usually makes you
better at something. But when it comes
to trading, there are infinite ways to
actually trade the market. And so, you
are going to overload yourself with
information. You actually don't need a
lot of information to become successful
at trading. I've always found that
simpler is better. And so what most
people do, and I did this myself, is I
would say, "Oh, well, you know, this
strategy just doesn't work, and let me
go find a new one or add, you know,
another indicator that helps confirm my
trades that will increase my win rate."
And in reality, that doesn't really
work. You are essentially starting over
from square one. Now, when you're
starting out and you're learning new
strategies, it's important to go learn a
bunch of different strategies because
you don't know, you know, what works
with kind of your style and how you want
to trade and you're just starting to
learn. But once you kind of do that, you
got to really be aware that you are
going to be stuck in this cycle really,
really easily if you don't stop yourself
from learning more and more strategies.
And so how you break out of this is
committing to one strategy. You know
over time what I realized was simpler
was better. And I came up with kind of
essentially this 30 minute reversal
strategy where I only trade 60 minutes a
day roughly in the morning. And I look
for one specific pattern. I used to try
and think oh I can capture you know
every move in the market. Anytime the
market goes up that's a missed
opportunity. every time it goes down.
That's, you know, something I should
have been able to read into a pattern
and figure out that the market was going
to do that and I should have been able
to capture that move and make profit off
of that. But instead, what I've realized
over time is executing the exact same
strategy and looking for a specific
pattern every day and waiting for that
specific pattern is way more profitable
because you are waiting for the market
to fit you versus trying to fit the
market. And that's reactionary and
that's not a profitable way to trade.
And so for me, I literally look for this
is just a bunch of pictures of charts of
trades that I've taken of saying I just
look for the same thing. The market
opens for me at this time. I look to see
if the market has a big, you know, move
in one direction and then I look for
essentially a double bottom in the
market kind of 30 minutes after the S&P
500 opens. That's what I trade. I trade
S&P 500 futures 30 minutes after it
opens. I've realized that that's kind of
a timing where the market likes to
reverse. And so if that lines up with
the market doing a double bottom, that's
a really good buy signal for me. And I
just repeat that over and over. These
are all different days where you can see
the market opens, it spikes down, it
makes essentially a double bottom,
there's a nice big bullish candlestick.
I buy above that big candlestick and it
it fits that same pattern every day and
I wait for that same pattern and if that
pattern shows up I take it and if it
doesn't I just move on with the day and
it's able to be very very repeatable and
very simple and this has helped me break
out of that cycle of trying to
constantly find new things because you
can see every day is slightly different.
You know, sometimes the market spikes up
and I look for a double top instead and
bet the market's going to go down. And
sometimes it it's just choppy and
there's no good trade. Or some days it's
just sitting there and does nothing or
trends in one direction really fast and
I get no trade. And that's okay. You
don't need to be making money
consistently every day to be
consistently profitable trader. No
pattern or strategy is successful in
every market condition. What you want to
do is realize that what can I be
successful with and then focus and
narrow down on that. Start a trading
journal and start tracking your trades
and essentially mastering that one
strategy because that's what's going to
break you out of this loop because
otherwise you're just starting from
square one all the time and you're just
going to be stuck in that cycle. And I
was stuck in that cycle for years and
years. And I know a ton of my students
are just the same. And you got to
remember when it comes to what the
trading journey looks like with any
strategy that you start out, you're
going to start out losing money or just
not making any money at all. Even with a
strategy that you could be profitable
with in the future, you're not going to
make money with it right away. you're
going to be losing money because you're
going to need to start mastering that
strategy. And also, once you break out
of that learning loop and start focusing
and mastering one strategy, it doesn't
mean you're just going to magically
start shifting your profit graph and
you're going to go up from there.
actually what changes your chart to
becoming consistently profitable and
breaks you out of, you know, kind of
slowly losing money and becoming
consistently profitable with a strategy
is you're then going to get stuck in
what I call the self-sabotage loop. And
that's because you are going to start
executing and trying to consistently
match your trades. Like for example, if
you're executing my strategy every day,
you see this setup, but all of a sudden,
you know, this happens and your strategy
says, "Okay, I need a buy." But you get,
you know, scared and instead you don't
take that setup and you miss out on a
profitable trade. Or you jump in too
early, like somewhere down here, and the
market stops you out when it makes one
more push down while it's making that
double bottom. and you get stopped out
when the market makes one more push down
confirming that double bottom. That's
when you're starting to get FOMO. And so
the self-sabotage loop comes from your
emotions and you negatively impacting
your ability to consistently properly
execute this strategy. What allows you
to turn your profit graph to
consistently making money is learning
how to actually manage how your emotions
negatively impact your trading. Everyone
is slightly different. They have
different emotions that will control
their trading more. But the idea is, you
know, you have either greed that makes
you, you know, jump into a trade too
early, take a loss, and that messes up
how your strategy is actually supposed
to work, or you have fear of getting in
a trade, and so you miss out on a
profitable trade, affecting the results
of how your trading strategy should
actually work. And so you have to go in
and think about what emotions am I
feeling and how they are affecting my
trading. How does the impulsivity that
comes into me when I feel fear or
nervousness or I have FOMO which is the
fear of missing out of you know a
potential trade. How do I react based on
that? The whole thing with trading is
you can feel all these emotions. I still
feel all these emotions but I don't let
the emotions control me. That's the
biggest thing when it comes to trading
is controlling your actions how you
want. You don't have to be an
emotionless robot to be successful at
trading. It's actually the opposite.
It's you need to feel all these
emotions, but learn how to react
properly to them. Change how you react
to them. And instead of, you know,
revenge trading and taking, you know,
having massive blowup days or weeks
where you, you know, jump in, uh, trades
just based out of frustration, you
instead stop yourself from doing that
and say, "Hey, I need to just be done
with trading for the day and move on,
reset, and come back the next day and
consistently wait for my pattern and
strategy to show up." And so how you
break out of this is you have to kind of
figure out what your self-sabotage loop
looks like. And so to walk you through
what my self-sabotage loop is so you can
kind of see how it works, how it maybe,
you know, gives ideas to how yours
works. And then we'll talk about how you
can break out of it. And so how my
self-sabotage loop was worked was I
always had a massive fear of being wrong
with my trades. I was always scared that
my trade would not work. You know that
this one time that I'm getting in, the
trade's not going to work out. Even
though trading is it's like you're going
to the casino, right? You're it's all
percentage based. You're not going to
win every trade. Logically, I always
knew, yeah, my win rate could be 50%,
but I, you know, make three times amount
that I lose. So, every time, you know, I
lose a trade, let's say I lose $100, but
every time I win a trade, I win $300.
Well, at a 50% win rate, you're making
consistent money over the long term. But
when it comes down to trading, I would
have kind of that narrow tunnel vision
would come in. That fear would kind of
make me just tunnel vision on this one
trade and the fear would overwhelm me
and control my actions and I would end
up skipping the trade. And usually
because you know for me most of the time
when I showed up to trading I was dialed
in focused waiting for my strategy and a
lot of times my read would be pretty
good. I would notice that that pattern
and it was a good trade and so I would
end up skipping a good trade skipping
out on you know profits. I would then be
frustrated because it was you know it
pissed me off that I missed a profitable
trade and I really should have been in
it. I knew I should have been in it. I
just got a little scared, hesitated, and
especially for me trading on, you know,
a smaller time frame like a one minute
chart, things happen quickly. You have
to take action right away. You can't
kind of sit there on like on a higher
time frame and kind of let the emotions
kind of ease out a little bit and, you
know, jump in. A lot of times by the
time, you know, I get over that initial
fear, the trade would be gone. You know,
the market would have already, you know,
shot up in the favor of that direction
that I was thinking and it would be too
late. So then, you know, I'm frustrated.
I would continue to watch the charts
because, you know, I said, well, you
know, maybe another setup will show up,
right? And so I would then FOMO or
impulsively jump into a bad trade. You
know, it would start to set up or it
would, you know, I'd cut a few corners,
right? Like let's say I I have my
five-step entry checklist that I wait
for every time. Well, instead, you know,
I I get four out of five and I say, you
know, whatever. It's good enough. I just
miss a trade. I I gotta get in here. I'm
not going to miss another one. And so I
would jump in, you know, with FOMO and
that impulsivity. It would control me
and I'd say I'd jump in and it would
normally turn into a loss because, well,
it's a trade I just shouldn't have been
in anyway. And of course then that loses
that's now two losses on the day and I
would then, you know, be really
frustrated. Sometimes it would be, you
know, worse than frustrated. You know,
there's going back to these that there
would be, you know, some days it would
turn into kind of hopelessness or
desperation. You know, if I'm kind of on
a losing streak, it'd be just like, I'm
just I keep doing this. You know, I'm
stuck in this cycle of constantly, you
know, blowing up my account or going on
these losing streaks and I can't seem to
make things work, right? And then
eventually after that, you know, some
days I would even revenge trade. You
know, I'd frustrate and take another
loss. And eventually though, I would,
you know, be done for the day. I'd be
like, "Okay, I have to be done. I got to
cut my losses. Things aren't working
out. And I'd take a break, right? And I
would essentially reset your normally
I'd, you know, be done for the day and I
would reset and it would come back as
the next morning and I'd be good to go.
You know, I for me I can reset over the
night usually pretty well, feel
refreshed and kind of focused again,
ready to trade and it would start that
same loop over and over of that fear of
being wrong. you know, that a setup
would come and I'd get nervous and I'd
skip the trade. And so, this was kind of
that cycle that even though I had a good
strategy, I would be stuck in and it
would stop me from becoming profitable.
And so, let's now talk about some
actionable steps for you to break out of
this self-sabotage loop. Now, the first
thing is through this video, you have
already started to build your awareness.
You need to go through your trading and
start to just realize, okay, what are my
emotions? What are they doing? You know,
is it FOMO that is messing me up? Is it,
you know, nervousness? Is it greed? Go
through and think about your trades and
make a list of, you know, what's
damaging your trading. And then you need
to go in and say, okay, how am I
reacting to those emotions? How are they
affecting my trading? And how am I
trading when I, you know, feel those
emotions? Am I impulsively jumping into
a trade or am I stopping and not getting
into a trade when I really should be?
What you need to do is make a trading
journal and start to track and build
this list from your trading. Every time
you take a trade, go in and write down
your emotions of what you felt when you
entered in on that trade or what you
felt when you were managing the trade.
You know, did you get out too early of
your trade because of fear? you didn't
want to give out your profits or you let
the trade go on too long out of greed
and you gave up way more than you should
have because the you know the trade came
back against you and you know initially
you know you kind of saw the market
going up and you said okay I should
probably get out here but you know you
kind of got money eyes and the euphoria
were like well what if it just keeps
going all the way up why would I want to
get out here but in reality the trade
you know you saw this spot you know
maybe it was at a resistance zone up
here and instead it it reversed right
there and you would have got out at the
tippity top. And then the next stages of
that is well from understanding these
reactions and building your awareness
you'll start to realize okay well how do
I want to react based on that most of
the time it's you know the good default
is well I want to follow my plan you
know if my plan says to jump in on a
trade here I jump in no matter what I
feel if I'm scared that's okay I accept
it and I jump in on the trade that's how
you overcome you know your emotions
controlling you and impulsively you know
either jumping you in on a trade or
getting out too soon. And then of the
then last one is you start consistently
reacting correctly. And what that kind
of looks like is, you know, here's your
kind of normal cycle of, you know, stuck
in that fear of being wrong. You know,
for me, this was my cycle, right?
Instead, I've created a new cycle, a
better cycle that essentially helps me
be profitable. And I will jump in the
trades consistently. And essentially,
it's I'll see a setup, I'll be kind of
nervous that it's maybe not going to
work out. You know, that fear of being
wrong still comes up. Trading is still
intense even when you've done it for
years and years because, you know,
you're always increasing that size. It's
always intense still, right? And so
instead though, I'll feel that emotion,
accept it, and say, "Well, I want to
follow my plan anyway." And I take the
trade. And so I take the trade. You
know, sometimes it doesn't work out, but
a lot of the time I have shifted my
mindset to say, well, me jumping in on a
trade that sets up how I want, that's a
good trade. It doesn't matter if it wins
or loses. Instead, a successful trade
for me is if it was a good trade setup,
if I jumped in when I knew I should have
and when the patterns aligned with what
I'm waiting for and looking for every
day. And so from there, that helps me
build confidence because I traded how I
want to trade. If you're doing this and
consistently executing through your
emotions and you're still, you know, not
profitable, that just means you have to
go back through your trading journal and
tweak things. That's where, you know,
you really start to narrow down what's
working and what isn't. A lot of the
time you will find that if you can take
out a ton of the losing trades or you're
ones that consistently lose, there's
some common denominator of why. And if
you take a lot of those out and you can
through, you know, collecting that data
and reviewing your journal, it'll
drastically pump up your win rate and
how much profit you're making
consistently. And so from there, you
know, it makes that new cycle of instead
of, you know, my muscle memory being to
skip the trade, my now muscle memory
and, you know, kind of mental pattern is
to take a trade and I'm now essentially,
you could say, stuck in a cycle that is
positively impacting my trading versus
one that's negatively impacting my
trading. So, really take the time to
think about this and how it is affecting
you and your trading because it's really
going to help you become consistently
profitable. So, I'm jumping along here.
We've had a really nice flush lower in
the opening 15 minutes and big picture,
we've had a big sell-off overnight. And
so, I think uh we might have a
essentially a fake lower here and then a
rip higher potential. Um so, I didn't I
this was a little too aggressive to get
it on this candlestick because it could
just pop up here. um you know recover
this a little bit and then continue
lower but seeing it pull back here um
essentially make a higher low and then I
got in on the break of this swing high
here so that essentially confirms it's
making a higher low and starting to make
higher highs as well. You know, pretty
much the opening price is here and so I
don't think I'll go break even until it
kind of comes up here to 2x. Big
picture, it'd be sick. You know, just
looking at a fivem minute a and even to
pull down a 15-minute. Big big picture
here is, you know, we've been in a
strong uptrend and we had FOMC
yesterday. Lots of volatility.
Good potential to rip back up today. Um,
I don't know if I'll be able to hold
through that whole move, which is
totally fine. Um, I would rather just
capture the initial easy spike this
morning, but I do want to
try and be be patient with this because
sometimes these flushes in the morning,
it could pop up here, pull back, and
then rip higher. Um, and because today
has
such a high volatility chance,
I want to give it some wiggle room. Um,
you know, it's it's it's really easy and
nice to try and go break even early,
take that risk off the table so you're
not scared and nervous about losing that
money um or or giving up your profits.
But it's a lot better usually to just go
with what the market is telling you. And
I could totally see it come down here,
retest this low, which is yesterday's
huge swing low off of um
FOMC. And so as it rockets up here
though, um what I want to be looking at
is I'm not going to get out on a 3x
here. I think maybe a four if it just
spikes like that. Um,
but I do want to see
how this initial pullback plays out. Um,
it's scary kind of risking
giving back essentially all this profit
and the loss here, but in reality it's
really unlikely just spikes like that.
Um, this is a really good signal. NASDAQ
is recovering as well. ES is stronger
this morning and that's why I went in on
the ES. Um, you could see based on just
this pullback right here, these two
candlesticks. If we compare that to
these two candlesticks on NASDAQ, a lot
weaker. And so I took the NASDAQ over
that. Um, and so as this goes kind of
parabolic here, um,
I like to get out if it breaks that
because it there is it's hard because
there is big potential today and a big
picture to continue higher, but there's
also
these
I just want to mark these as minor
reversal zones which can cause
a move that's this aggressive to turn
around.
Um, so
that's kind of what I'm seeing here
today. I think at this point because
I've hit 2x, I'm going to go break even.
If it pulls all the way back here, I'm
going to get out. I don't want to risk a
loss at that point.
That's a nice little one candlestick
pullback. Um, this is a huge
candlestick.
And I don't want to get greedy here
because this is kind of crazy movement.
Um,
I just want to see what for where Forex
is
at a spot where we are. I'm going to
start I I'm pretty much having a mental
stop at this point because this is just
going crazy and obviously I've been p
super patient the whole week.
Um,
and this is, you know, my heart rate is
spiking and I'm nervous and excited. Um,
I, you know, I basically have to hold
back here, hold a pullback here. I'm
going to close these out here just
knowing that it's hitting this is
important. Um,
I want to give it
a little more room here. I'm just trying
to look at where a 50% pullback is.
Okay, we've already done that. Never
mind. Um,
in terms of management, I mean,
obviously, I'm going to get out if it
comes all the way down here. I would
like to get out somewhere up here,
obviously, if it's going to stop, but I
also want to see it pull back here and
push higher a bit more. In these
uptrends, they can have little pullbacks
like this. Um, and so
I want to give it room. It's not really
at a big level to where I would expect a
reversal.
But once this spikes up one more time,
I'm going to get out. I'm happy with
that profit. I don't need to be going
for $10,000
um with how fast this is moving because
this could just rip lower on a dime
here. I think if it chop starts to chop
here one or two more candles, I'll pull
my stop up here.
But I would really love it if we broke
higher and I hit 6K on a trade. That
would be my biggest trade so far at this
size. And obviously that would be a
shitload of money.
But, you know, you can't think about the
money too much. You need to focus on
what the market's telling you and
following your strategy. And my strategy
is try and hold with this uptrend until
it tells me otherwise. And it's starting
to slow down here.
But it also looks like it could make one
more break higher.
Trying to be patient here, not let the
nerves um
get get me out here
because this is a huge strong candle and
it's really just flagging out here. And
if it spikes here and rips lower, then
I'll get out as well. That's a good
signal.
I'm going to tighten up below this
candlestick.
And I think it's either going to rip
continue to rip after that chop right
there or it's going to slow down.
And I'm just going to leave my my limit
where it is.
I'm totally happy getting out if it if
it does that and rips lower.
I of course obviously it was so close to
getting my limit there which sucks, but
getting out right here is still a sick
win. It's still 3x. Really?
Just waiting. Yeah, we're out. This is
it. This is the month where I make a run
at it. I am going to try to make $30,000
in one month trading by tripling my
trading size. Once you can consistently
make money with a smaller amount, all
you need to do to make more money is
increase your size. So, that's what I'm
going to do this month. I'm going to
show you every trade I take, walk you
through every part of the process, good
or bad, keep you updated on any changes
I make, and how adjusting to the new
size increase affects me and my trading.
>> Order filled.
>> And then I'm just going to have my
target somewhere up here at the open.
Yeah, at this point it doesn't look
great just because the ES is just kind
of continuing lower. or I think if the
ES was going to bounce, it would have
done it right here. Now,
riskreward-wise, I think it's still
just, you know, it was a decent looking
trade. 50/50 kind of thing, and I think
the 50/50 would have been a great, you
know, riskreward, but knocked out. Looks
like it's just going to continue lower.
So, I lost over $5,000 this week. I've
never lost that much money in trading
before in one week. It's because I made
a lot of dumb mistakes. I just sized up
and I've realized when you size up the
money is a lot more intense and so
you're way more likely to revert back to
some dumb mistakes you made on Monday. I
got in way too early. I didn't wait for
a really good spike and flush lower kind
of a final fake out that I really find
way more high probability and I you know
instead had some FOMO thought oh what if
I jump in right here and or or I don't
jump in here and I I wait for a better
setup and I miss out on a trade and you
know now I'm thinking well that you know
if I miss out on a trade that's three or
four or you know $5,000 that's a big key
I need to not do. The second one is
betting against really strong momentum.
As a reversal trader, I'm always betting
counter trend in a way, but I always try
and make sure that the trend is clearly
over and has high chance to be done and
looking to reverse. But I've noticed
over time is that when there is a really
strong momentum move that it doesn't
reverse right away. A lot of the time it
takes time for that momentum to work
itself out. And so I know in those spots
that it's better to just not take a
trade there and know that it's less
likely and less probable. And instead I
jumped in and took the trade.
The third one was betting against the
big picture trend
>> cuz it looks like it has momentum
potential. Of course it could not, but
the risk of waiting too long is just it
it just goes without me. what is the
trend over the past couple days, past
couple weeks, and I took a trade in
gold. It had a nice move up into a
resistance level, but I thought going
into that day that the major trend was
to the upside and so it was more likely
that once it hits that resistance level,
it's just going to maybe slow down for a
minute, but it's going to continue
higher. And I tunnel visioned, looked
at, you know, the micro trend and
thought, well, it looks like, you know,
it's giving me some micro patterns and
signals that it could reverse. It
started to reverse but really did a fake
out to the downside and then shot higher
again because that big picture trend
came back into play once it had a
pullback. And so those are three big
lessons I need to use going into this
week. I'm going to make a a piece of
paper on my desk so I can tangibly focus
on the key major mistakes I think I
commonly make now, especially when the
size is bigger. And so hopefully I can
avoid those dumb mistakes and make some
money going into this next week.
>> But I like the potential to go lower.
>> Just going to enter in and and um then I
can explain it in a second more.
Um so big picture,
the market is bullish and so it's had
this massive move up. Um but
it's also hitting this trend line. Um
and I I want to see I kind of need to
see how it reacts to this previous high.
Part of me feels like I'm going against
my rules a little bit of really strong
uptrend. Just trying to look at this.
See if I want to move my stop down. I
don't think yet. I think I want to move
my stop down if it starts to punch down
to here. just because of my lack of
confidence in the trade, my upsetness
with myself or frustration of myself of
kind of I don't know, feeling like I
broke my rules a little.
Okay. Well, small loss on that.
Okay. So, after
breaking my rules for a couple days. I
have wrote down on a sheet kind of what
directions I think and trades I want for
each market. I'm going to get long.
I'm a little nervous. ES is hitting
highs,
but I'm going to get long here. Big
picture is aligned. There is a nice
bottoming pattern with a flush here.
Downtrend into this area isn't crazy.
>> Order filled. you know, initial target
will definitely be the open and we'll
just kind of see how
things get going here.
Really gross.
I'm going to go long on this. The idea
that it's basically faked lower
and it's going to continue
and break this and continue higher with
the trend. And this is just a pullback
in instead of looking for a reversal
here.
Order filled.
I'm going move my target up a bit more
because I don't want to get knocked out
on a spike with just the idea that this
market is very volatile. It has the
potential.
Order filled.
>> Big picture on a five minute. I think it
looks really good potential wise, but
I'm also nervous that it's just doing a
little
retracement here
of this move and then failing.
Just going to move to a five minute for
now because it's just choppy and I mean
it's either going to knock me out or it
doesn't, right? Yeah. I'm trying to in
some spots since the market's been so
trendy is looking for some of these
reversals to fail where, you know, it
has a strong uptrend. It hits a level,
does a pullback and starts to make some
nice price action to go higher to
continue that uptrend. This one, I don't
know. I think I force this one a little
bit. I think in better spots, the better
signal is when it hits this level and
starts to chop a little bit versus this
was chopping too long. And so it might
just go into a chop fest.
Pretty gross.
So, I'm down over 11K in the last two
weeks and I've never been down that much
money before and it it feels emotional
and I, you know, feel like a failure and
I've kind of lost confidence in my
ability to execute my trading strategy.
It's not the strategy that's losing me
money. It's the fact that every day I'm
going in focusing on the money and not
focusing on the process and not focusing
on being patient of wanting to take a
trade. Uh that aligns up with my
strategy versus, you know, oh, you know,
oh, there's a potential trade here and
jumping in on it and I'm not getting in
when I need to be, right? And so I'm
trading very uh emotionally and all over
the place. And so what I'm trying to do
now is reenter myself because
the market is always going to be there
and I don't need to take trades every
day to be successful especially at the
size now. That's what has really kind of
u made me go a little crazy I think is
that the size is so big now that I can
take one trade and make you know 5k from
it or if I um size up a little it could
be like 10k and that's uh kind of
mind-blowing. And so dealing with that
has made me need to realize I need to,
you know, focus on the process and go
into every day not caring about uh if I
take a trade that day and if I make
money or not. The focus needs to be on
uh a good successful trading day needs
to be if I go in and take a trade that
is based on my strategy, not if I go in
and make money or lose money. And so
that's what I want to do going into this
next week and going into the next couple
weeks. I don't want to frame it as uh
even for this video, oh, it's a success
if I can dig myself out of this hole.
That that could take longer. Um, you
know, doesn't depending on what happens
with my trading and the market, right?
And so I want to a win needs to be if I
go in and take trades that I want and
take trades that I like versus jumping
in on trades and making money. Um
because that's again going to keep me in
that emotional driven state of FOMOing,
of being nervous, being scared, and
tunnel visioning and and just continuing
to lose money. With that being said,
hopefully the comeback starts now and I
can focus up this week and just take a
couple of trades when they come along
and focus on being patient because
that's what's going to make me money in
the long run.
Okay, let's get this train rolling. It
is a fresh week. I am going into this
week with the idea of I'm trying to just
execute my strategy how I see fit and be
super patient. Um, a win is, you know,
uh, getting my trade and strategy when
it shows up versus trying to take trades
and make money in the market. The ES and
the NASDAQ are not aligned, which
doesn't look good for trading either of
them. Usually I like to have them kind
of be move in the same direction because
it's more likely that they do something.
Took a quick break, but
uh you know ES is just choppy. NASDAQ
had a little spike at the open, but it's
still just choppy. I'm just going to
call it a day. Totally happy with that.
No need to push it when there's really
nothing going on.
It's made a nice higher low.
off of this area I've looked for. It's a
double bottom head and shoulders. I
mean, off of this previous high here,
nice bounce there and then a bounce
here. So, that's pretty dang good
structure. The only thing is I feel like
my intuition is kind of saying that this
is um it's already had two big moves for
the day.
>> Order filled.
And I'm just nervous about this gold
trade just because it is a little later
than I normally take a trade and it
feels like uh could just be getting
choppy but also I'm just nervous because
I'm scared about the outcome. You know
what if it list loses here
but you know again the reasons to get in
were solid and that's that's what I want
to be focusing on, right? It's not about
the trade outcome. It's about the
process of executing when it's follows
your strategy and pushing through that
nervousness and emotion.
That could be a a break of this trend.
Now, I need to see a couple candlesticks
and see what it does. But I think at
this point, I'll move my stop loss up to
here at least. I would really be kind of
upset to get out here.
You know, getting out here still, I was
happy with how I traded. I think I
stayed in it. you know, getting it out
somewhere up here would have just been,
I think, kind of, I don't know, more
emotional and just because the trend was
still in play. There was no reason to
get out based on the charts until now.
Um, so still a nice trade. Nice to get a
something in the books, but bummer that,
you know, to get knocked out here
because part of me is like, oh, it looks
like it could just knock out and then
reverse, but you know, that's That's the
signal I'm going with and I'm going to
call it a day on that.
Gold is potentially getting that
pullback. I'd like I actually think I
would get long here on this as it's come
up and it's it's done a 50% pullback.
It's gone past that actually. And if it
pulls back and breaks higher, I think
that's a good it's just a really good
sweep lower. It's kind of nerve-wracking
getting in on this volatility
a little bit,
>> but
I like it to the long side.
>> Okay, definitely some whips saws here on
gold. That's kind of spooky, but held
through the pullback I want. And you
know, that's that's what I'm looking
for.
Dang. So, I had a break even or not a
break even, a loss on that. I really
thought that pullback was going to look
good. Seven contracts. Holy I
almost accidentally did seven.
>> That would have been not a good time.
>> I like this on a fivem minute. Just
using a one minute as an entry signal
and a five minute looks really good.
But again, I'm not going to touch it.
I don't want to get out just because I'm
scared. You know, the big picture is a
nice signal. We could pull up a little
bit more, make a new high on the ES and
then and then start sell off.
Okay, out on that trade.
So this is the end of week three and I
am still really in the hole. But going
through this process, I've realized and
you know kind of after week two when I
was in that emotional spiral is and this
week I feel like I've I've started to
write the ship. Maybe not in results
yet, but I started to refocus on
the important parts of trading. And this
week I've done a lot better job of
refocusing and saying, you know, taking
stuff away and saying, "Okay, it doesn't
matter about the results. I have to
focus on the process. Taking away
trading gold and oil and saying, "Okay,
I know I can be good at focusing on just
those morning reversals and just trading
those and being patient and not forcing
trades, not following, not feeling like
I have to make this money back because I
am in such a hole." And so next week I
have to go into the week focus on the
process because that's what actually
makes money trading and be disciplined
in my execution because right now having
an 8% win rate is really not reflective
of I think my strategy and my ability.
It's me being in this emotional death
spiral. You know it's a part of trading
of of adjusting and putting all this
pressure on myself. that I have to
adjust quickly because otherwise I'm
going to lose a lot of money and I'll
come out of it on the other side
hopefully being a better trader and
being able to make more money.
And so I, you know, don't really know if
I'll take much of a trade today. I don't
plan on trading very long cuz I, you
know, had my 50k ultramarathon over the
weekend. I am completely exhausted.
Let's go.
>> Trading a long time today is not going
to be a smart thing because I won't make
good decisions. Um I'm sitting in my
chair right now. I pretty much always
stand when I'm trading. Standing on my
legs right now just doesn't work very
well. So I wanted to show up to the
markets today and kind of see what was
going on. Take a a trade if it sets up
really perfectly. But, you know, if it
if it's kind of in that middle ground,
uh, where we are right now, you know,
where it's like, uh, middle of the
range, not a high probability
high probability level, um, there's just
no point in in forcing things.
There's no really strong read and so I'm
just going to call it. Um, there's no
reason to try and force anything.
I think that's a good enough signal
there for me. And again, with the NASDAQ
having the ability to really spike
higher here, I'm going to jump in.
Nice confirmation on the ES so far.
Still hasn't confirmed that's broken
that, but I'm just going to let this
play out. I like the entry. It's
following my timing, my strategy, you
know, head and shoulders here. And I was
waiting till both kind of aligned.
just nervous especially with
this still I don't know kind of selling
off here at this downtrend
ideally I should really have my stop
below here
knocks me out there but I mean I figured
that hey it's either going to go up or
it's going to fail here
I think I made some good discipline
moves this week um in terms of jumping
off when I wasn't, you know, sure and
essentially just getting more aligned
with how I should be trading my strategy
and that's the whole goal of trading for
me going through adjusting to this big
size. Now, you know, I haven't really
got a win yet, which is really
frustrating and rough, um which, you
know, causes um me to feel like I'm
going to fall back into that emotional
spiral.
But trying to limit that and and stay on
the right side of things and being
patient and knowing that it will come
and that I don't need to adjust my
strategy that the market's, you know,
been tricky right now in terms of making
huge moves and that triggering FOMO. I
mean, it was a tough trading week and I
only took one loss. So, that's a huge
improvement on what was happening
before. I'm going to trade next week and
hopefully come into next week and you
know at the end of the day like I am two
wins away from being break even. That's
what I have to remember. I don't need
that many trades to make a lot of money
with this strategy.
Okay, coming into today, I've taken a
few days off from trading. And so, it
helps me to get back into the swing of
things by visualizing what I want to do,
reminding myself how my strategy works
and what I'm looking for. You know, what
is that repeatable thing that I'm
looking for every day versus just kind
of showing up and being like, okay, I'm
just going to trade. Uh, market hasn't
opened yet. Got 7:30. my time is when it
opens and then other couple windows I
like 7:45 and 8. These are my two spots
where I want to see it come down and
reverse if it's, you know, either way at
those timings. That's kind of lines up
with what is repeatable for me versus I
find, you know, going into the market
and just trying to enter in randomly
just does not work very well.
So, what I would like for a long here
now that it's broken the lows, I would
want a head and shoulders to go long
here because otherwise if it's way more
likely that we just especially for the
NASDAQ here is come up here, test this,
and just continue lower because we're
not really bouncing off of a a support
level. Now, we we could just be doing a
failed breakout at the overnight lows
here, but big picture, we could just be
in a downtrend. Um, that's going to
continue lower. You know,
I like this to the upside.
I really want to see I'm nervous that
I'm just going to
>> order filled. It's just going to pump me
in and then rip lower. But I think I'm
just going to get in long
um through that nervousness because it
it's made a nice head and shoulders
there. I'm gonna just put my stop down
here.
Spiking all the way back up here. I'm
going to go to break even. I want to
just see where we are at here. But a lot
of the times recently, I feel like it's
hit the open and then
slowed down. And so getting out at just
2x has been really good to do. I'll see
how we hit 2x, I think. And then I think
maybe I'll go previous candlestick with
the trailing stop. If this also reverses
here, I'll probably move my stop up here
as well.
I definitely if this starts popping up
here, I'm going to move trailing stop
like really tight here now.
like up to 2x.
NASDAQ is popping as well. For me,
mentally, I feel like getting 5K on the
trade is kind of a mental number I
really want right now. It's not good,
but that's just the reality. But I also
don't want to just let that control what
I'm doing. I want to run a trailing stop
here if this is just going to continue
to pop. I don't think that's over greed.
I I'm just going to put a trailing stop
here right at the bottom of this candle
because I think either it's going to
keep going up or it's going to knock me
out.
And if it knocks me out here at 4700,
I'm totally happy with that.
Come on, hold, hold, and keep going.
That's okay. I'm totally happy with
that. But six start to the day, six
start to the week. That is exactly what
I want to be doing in the mornings. And
that's my repeatable setup right there.
You know, get the emotions of managing
it and dealing with this. If I wasn't as
triggered by the money right now, I
would have held through this and let it
do a 50% pullback and let it go higher.
But all things considered, I waited for
that setup. This is exactly what I
wanted and that's what I want to be
doing with my trading. That's what's
repeatable and that's how I will be
consistently profitable.
So, we're coming down to the support
zone on the NASDAQ. So, we've had a nice
pullback and we're coming into this
15-minute reversal timing. So, normally
I'd be looking for, you know, potential
long here. Uh, the problem is if we look
at the ES, it's just chopping here. It's
just opened up and really done nothing.
And I have been trying to drill into my
head.
If they're not aligned, I don't take a
trade.
Okay, so NASDAQ and ES are just sitting
here chopping. We just opened and
chopped. It didn't really do what I was
looking for. We're coming up on 8:00,
you know, the 30 minute window. The
15-minute window right here didn't
really make sense. It just kind of
sitting here chopping. Uh, you know, and
again, I I want to be going into every
day looking for the 15 or 30 minute
reversal. And if it doesn't show up,
just call it. just move on. Don't get
sucked in of trying to capture a win
today. If it doesn't show up, it doesn't
show up. There's no point in trying to
stay and figure this out because it
could just chop here forever.
I'm sure it eventually goes some
direction, but is that tradable? And is
that consistently tradable for me to
repeat over and over? And in my
experience, for me, no. And so, I'm just
going to call it and move on the next
day.
The last five weeks have been a roller
coaster for me. I think now the last
like two weeks have been way more
focused and exactly how I want to trade
and how I know how to be profitable
trading. And the first two weeks, if you
look at, you know, kind of just go back
in the video and look at how emotional I
was, how focused on the results I was,
and how I was kind of in just like this
emotional death spiral. When you look at
my my results was destroying my trading.
And I think that's exactly what happens
to every trader when they get way too
focused on the results or the money gets
too big and and you just get in that
tunnel vision. I really had that for the
first two weeks and having to reset
myself and, you know, find a a a bottom
and essentially rewrite the ship. Um, so
I didn't, you know, start to burn tens
of thousands of dollars now at my new
size and doing that while trying to, you
know, film it all and everything was it
it made it very it added to the
intensity. And so, um, you know, that's
something I wasn't used to and adjusting
to that took a couple weeks. And um now
going forwards, you know, over the these
last two weeks, you can I I can really
see looking back is my focus has got to
the right mindset and the right way I
want to be thinking about trading and
the right way any successful trader
should think about trading because at
the end of the day, you know, it's about
doing what I personally can consistently
and profitably do and repeat every
single day, you What I was trying to do
in the first two weeks was
jump in and you know try and just read
the market in real time and capture
every move that the day has even if it's
in my morning window. Um and I can't
consistently do that at the end of the
day. Um and it makes it too intense for
me. So now shifting back and regaining
that focus of, you know, I actually know
what I can be consistent with. And it's
just waiting for that 15-minute and that
30 minute reversal timing and waiting
for the markets to be aligned together.
And if I'm really confident in my read,
then I take a trade. But if it's kind of
back and forth, just close out. There's
no reason to force a trade. I have the
luxury of being patient and just saying,
"Hey, I'm just going to move on with the
day." Even if, you know, I stayed
another 10 minutes and maybe I caught a
trade, it's just not worth it. Just wait
for, you know, I could take four trades
a month and if I make, you know, four or
five from just those four trades being
wins, that's 20K a month. Next time I
size up, it gets bigger and bigger. So,
that's what I want to focus on going
forwards in my trading because that is
how I'm going to be consistently
profitable trading with this new size
over time. So now the next best thing
you can do is make sure to get that
90day roadmap via this QR code or in the
description below. It will have a great
stepbystep list for what you should be
doing and focusing on over the next 90
days. Plus, you'll get an email 24 hours
after that with all of my other detailed
free PDF guides like favorite
candlestick patterns, 75 trading lessons
I wish I knew sooner, and so much more.
Also, make sure to check out Ninja
Trader if you need a trading platform.
It's such a powerful platform, but also
simple, which is extremely important for
executing trades.